Uh my answer is I consider every single person that's actually
participating in that um discord to be basically the equivalent
of a terrorist. Um I think that you by giving your absolute legal
advice, most of which has been totally incorrect and the other
parts have illustrated you can barely read. Um I think make you
cob bro. You just let me know you still have videos saved to
your computer. You knew it was alleged that she was underage.
You still have them. Do you see how this is? Destiny says one.
I don't even know 100% if her age is legitimately less than 18
when these were taken.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay, let's go. I'm going to hit play on
this. And I'm still getting ready for stream. >> Wait,
what was my question? >> Wait, wait, wait. What was my
question
>> We're watching this again.
>> Start back. >> He's trying to get out of his uh
>> We'll catch up to me for reasons. >> what's this
about doxing people? No, he said, "What's so bad?" He said, "What's
so bad about people?" >> Oh, what's so bad about doxing
people? Oh, okay. Um, so if you just want to come on and justify
doxing people, I guess you can do that, but then I guess we'd
have to justify why you think like bada or uh julk or any of
these people that you've you've accused of doxing are bad. Like
why are they terrorists as you call them? >> Okay. I don't
know if my my mic is working right. Wick, can you hear me? Hello.
I can hear you. >> Wick. Okay, let me try one more time.
What is >> uh I will start from the beginning. I'm not
I'm going to start right now. >> So bad about doxing people.
What is bad about doxing? Why is it a bad thing to do? Why do
people generally think that
so much fun?
>> That's great. That's great. You just want to enjoy this.
We can talk about >> Proof that Darius went to see like
the
thing. He did it on screen.
Just I'm not advancing the conversation until he admits that
that was harassment. If he's not going to admit that, then I
haven't done anything. Actually, >> I'm going through that
show.
Yeah, but let Dub take. >> Yeah. Die. Die address it. Go
ahead. So, I'm going to pull the the emails for you Wick because
I think he's referring to this SA guy that he doxed, right? He
posted the document for the guy. Um, so far as I'm aware, these
were not threats. These were not harassing emails. I think the
what was in the emails from just off the top of my head was SA
saying, "Hey, just FYI, um, your being posted here's a link to
a nude review that's out there now. You here's how you try to
get it taken down." Um, I think he did ask her how old she was,
if I remember correctly, at the time she started speaking to
Destiny. >> Didn't he say didn't he say, "I did this as
a sign of good faith so that you would contact Joan Peters."
Yeah, I think he's trying to be helpful um to try to get this
woman to feel comfortable getting involved in the case. Yeah.
>> Do you know what you call that? That doesn't sound like
it's called manipulating and that's not harassment. Hold on.
That's not an implied threat or harassment. That's ridiculous.
>> You get like bonus disability for being mentally as
well or you don't think that that's implication
if he's lying. If he's just telling the truth, hey, there's a
case where you could help. Hey, could you go help these people?
That's not manipulation. That's a desperate. That's a plea. That's
just talking to human beings. You >> do. This is a sign
of good faith. let you know that the news are being shared without
being sent online. >> I'm still getting ready for >> Oh,
is that an implicit threat
>> or harassment? >> I can't believe the brain rot.
I just I can't believe the brain
>> when some when a stranger messages you and say and says,
"Hey, I know where a bunch of your personal information is posted
online." I went ahead and I took all that down for you as a show
of good faith. I really hope that you contact this other lawyer
and work with my friend in this case. And if you don't, I'm going
to be incredibly disappointed. >> Hold on. Did he say I'm
going to be incredibly disappointed? Hold on. And if he did,
do you consider that harassment? Him saying, "Hey, if you don't
get involved with I consider it worse than harassment." Yeah,
it's a threat. >> Okay, that's silly. But
let's say that any are deep fakes and all the text is fake, by
the way. You can't prove anybody when you posted
the [__] on forever.
Okay, this isn't going to work if you both are going to talk
over each other constantly. Do you guys finish your point and
then do Ry communicate with Darius and say, "Hey, please don't
come to my house." Is there any proof of him ever saying that?
>> I don't think he needs to. I think
hold on. Yeah, go ahead. >> Yeah, go ahead. So, when you
posted Destiny's uh not Destiny's Rose's photo and wearing the
DJ shirt and told them what like Universe was at and then bragged
that the only reason they do this girl is cuz you gave them that
information. Was that you harassing her?
>> All I'm trying to do is find out the information and
contact them. >> And you did that by giving it to Kiwi
Farms to help >> give anything to anybody. Wasn't Kiwi
Farms already posted in chat to Dr.
We're 2 seconds away from every single city in Illinois to try
to find. >> Why the [__] would you help them?
You posted at >> the time. The only information I had about
this person was that they leaked
>> So when he doxed them, it's
youually seeking out their help doxing this >> I was intentionally
seeking out a person who posted 27 revenge videos in my life.
Yes, I was. Yeah, I was trying to find out who this person was.
Would you agree that that would be a federal crime? >> Hold
on. Yeah, I agree. I encourage you. I encourage you to take them
to court and the solo guy. Yeah, I think what they did to you.
>> How am I supposed to take them to court if I don't even
know who they are? >> Why the [__] are you
using Hold on. Why the [__] are you using Kiwi Farms
to do that instead of the police? You
It's just a blatant lie.
>> How am I supposed to take some photo if I don't do this?
I'm sure with like private investigators and I don't think it's
reasonable investigator. >> I don't think it's reasonable
to post that internet for what you for a community that you think
is like a swatting doxing harassing community to try to find
this person which is what you did. And I have no other options.
I have no other. >> Didn't you contact this girl? Didn't
you also contact this girl on Facebook? >> Like is is that
after people found out who she was? Yes. >> With your help,
by the way. So after they found out who she was, you contacted
her on Facebook. Is that >> No, because after they blocked
me, I didn't reach out to him again. >> Okay. Well, did
Hold on. Did she block her? Hold on. Did she block Did she block
Did she block the Do you understand the difference? Do you understand?
Do you You can't block somebody via email. You do you understand
the difference between reaching out to somebody?
How would you know if somebody spam your email, Doobie? Tell
me. >> Okay. So, you have no evidence to be clear. You
have no evidence
to contact somebody not to contact her. How do you know your
email, Dy? How do you know somebody's blocked your email? >> Okay,
so again, how do you know that you blocked him or told him not
to contact >> How do you know somebody's blocked your >> Well,
we do have you posting her information. [clears throat] Hold
on. Hold on.
Die. Die. Doobie. Destiny. Both of you. Okay. Doobie, I do want
you to answer the question. How? Cuz I don't know. How do you
know if someone blocks your >> Yeah, I have no idea. But
as far as I'm aware, there's not as far as I'm aware, there's
no evidence that she told him not to contact her or uh or blocked
him, right? If you have that just for myification, wait, wait,
wait. If somebody's emailed like three or four family members
saying like, "Hey, I know this is your daughter. I need her to
respond to my email." She stopped responding. Hey, I know that
you might not know who I am, but I know you're a friend of this
person. I need you to tell her to respond to my emails. Does
it sound like the person doesn't maybe want to talk to that person
anymore? >> Well, let me let me ask this question, right?
Maybe in a different way. Um, Doobie, if I were to uh try to
get you on a panel and I kept asking and you stopped responding,
but then I started to DM um I don't know, people that you
At what point, if any, do you think it would be kind of harassment?
>> Um, I think if I told you to that I >> No, you
didn't say anything. But you just you just didn't say anything.
You didn't respond. >> I didn't say it. And I I would I'd
expect and I think you've done I think that people have done
this before with panels when I'm just not responding is I would
expect you to believe that maybe I just didn't see the DM. So
you're reaching out to somebody so they can only pass through
me in a voice channel >> like so unless you have some reason
to >> So unless you have some reason to believe if you
have some reason to believe that I'm not interested in speaking
to you or I'm not interested in whatever the then I I don't I
don't think you'd assume that it's harassment. you know, in the
case with like SIBA, um I can I can accept that like he had there
was an implication that she wasn't interested in pursuing this
thing.
That being the case, I don't think it makes any sense to be worked
up over him emailing her um or emailing family members to try
to get her to respond. Um when again, you posted her photo. >> You
don't think it's her university
and her university to help
exploitation down not bags find her. I think that's [__]
crazy. So
at the time at the time I'm posting looking for the person I
have no information for this person. I don't know who the [__]
they are. At the time he's emailing her. He knows more about
her and now he's engaged in an explicit campaign to force her
to cooperate in a civil case. >> Send hold on a campaign.
You're going to call that a campaign. >> 19
multiple family members across
her get involved with the >> Do you know that an email
implies a singular email? Did you know that an email usually
means one email? He admitted to 19
and he's emailed multiple family members of hers and her herself.
>> Okay. Again, I'm going to I'm going to adjust my claim.
Multiple emails to try to encourage her. [clears throat] >> So,
hold on. I believe basically all of those emails like I believe
13 or 14 of those emails are just saying, "Hey, I sent this request
here to get this profile taken down. Hey, I sent this request
here to get this profile taken down, which she was okay with
and responding to him back with right
>> case. And I think she shouldn't. Again, I think you
should char you should go after her criminally for what she did.
I I totally support that. >> Why? She didn't commit any
crimes. >> I don't think that's true. Um I think >> Well,
how do you know? Wait, what do you mean you don't think that's
true? >> Because from your story, um she was uh producing
selling. So was Solo. I think both these people should be charged
>> under threat by another adult that was printing her
out >> under a threat from the UK. That's your
>> I You're insane to me. That's the >> Didn't you
say Didn't you say that she didn't say that she went to like
hotel >> Let
finish. One of the same questions that got posed to her and she
was incredulous. Yes. A 17year-old can feel threatened by a guy
from another country. He's going to kill them. Yes.
>> You think that's impossible? Hold on. Wait. I just want
to hear you say you're telling me you're telling me you're telling
me that she that she went to a hotel to meet up with strangers
to to her on Skype so it could be recorded and given to you and
others because she was afraid of this guy in the UK. >> You
think that that's that's your story. That's what happened. >> Okay.
If you if you're incredulous about it, that's your story. I guess
that's fine. No, no, no. I think actually what happened I think
she's lying completely. I think she's been she's actually the
real demon. That's why
I think she lied about not being in touch with
But I again she has by the way what is the evidence of this?
No evidence by the way. None. But that's cool. You know believe
what you want. >> Okay. So again
um >> also I think wicked I think it is interesting that
you guys have said so many different claims about me through
this entire case. Basically every single one has been proven
to be false and basically my story hasn't changed really since
the very beginning that that I was [laughter] going to represent
myself that I was lying about. Did you speak to Rose or not?
Did you speak to Rose or >> Apparently not. No. >> So,
so this solo guy had someone pretend to be Rose and like like
a I guess convincingly enough that you didn't know this for after
multiple conversations. >> When somebody is sending me
a picture? >> No, Rose was obviously in the >> my
merch. Yeah. I assume that that's the actual person I'm talking
to. It was an extensive effort to catfish me. >> It was
Hold on. You said a phone call. You said there were a phone call.
>> No, I never talked to this person on the >> That
I don't think that's what you said in the the uh >> Do
you have uh Do you have transcripts where he did say it was a
phone call, Doobie? I said in one DM to Pixie on the day that
the that 27 leaks came out that I talked to this person on the
phone. I thought I had that was my recollection. I thought I
had I had spoke I didn't even DM with this person for like two
>> Okay. So you did say that. So you did say that. You
said you're fairly close and you had phone calls with her, right?
>> Yes, I said. Yeah, but I was incorrect. I hadn't had
I never >> So your story has changed, hasn't it? >> That's
not a story that I gave in testimony or in deposition or related
to the court. >> I'm not talking about the [__]
testimony. I'm not I'm not even the
one or two lines in a text log. Dude, is it not possible that
I could have been mistaken? I'm not
the same.
30 videos of me have been leaked online that my recollection
of that event at that particular point in time might not be 100%
accurate. Maybe I didn't actually talk on the phone. Maybe we
just DM'd a [__] >> Yeah, maybe you maybe
phone calls. Is that possible? Is that possible, Dy? Die. Is
that for a guy who talks to How many people online? Is it possible?
Is it more Is it more possible that you [__] lied
like you always lie all the [__] time? I think I
think that's funny on that. >> Destiny is just spuring
again like a child. He can't actually materially respond to anything
here. So, he's just going to spur like a child. >> I will
give you 10 to1 odds on any dollar amount you want relating to
to the facts of this court case as if you want. We can subpoena
as much and I try to get as much release you as you want. >> What
the case? I'm not talking about the [__] court case.
I'm intentionally lying. Just to be clear,
what are you referring to? How much money put it? Put a dollar
around. You said you brag about throwing our money to other people.
We can both wager on a $10,000 donation to um to wake if you
want. Doesn't have to go to me. You're running
away. Run away. Hold on. Dude, I just want to be clear.
>> You're running.
Hold on. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. >> Harassment. That's
real life harassment. >> Doobie. What? Doobie. What is
your claim specifically that's happening? Just so I
>> Here comes the up. >> Uh with arresting. I think
I think again the lie is that he had multiple calls with her.
I think they said even long calls with her, right? and this is
why he felt comfortable sending the news. Even though to be clear,
he sent them like within a week of speaking to this woman through
Discord. So, like this
ridiculous.
Um, so yeah, that's a lie. Um, I think there are a ton of lies
like this just all throughout this case, but pretty clear. I'm
not I'm not following your court case. I I really don't care
about it. Um, what I'm following is your behavior uh at the start
of that and then uh >> Wait, that was one claim. You said
there have been a ton of lies about this court case. So, the
first the first thing that you just brought up had it was not
there was no >> Hold on. Hold on, wait, wait. I didn't
say about the court case. What is the second lie about the court
case? I said there been a ton of lies about the court case. I
thought I heard you right now. Yeah. Hold on. Like I said, I'm
not following the court case. What I said what I'm talking about
is your behavior at the start of this and your behavior um since
this
lies. Another lie. Yeah. Another Okay. Another lie is uh you
said to um uh what's his name? Uh Willie Mack, right, about these,
right? Um you you told him you actually you acknowledge multiple
times. You hold on to you justified it. What I said was I can't
make a statement right now listening. Okay, for all that are
curious, the reason why I can't come out and make when I joke
about like oh who's asking the joke being is that if I say a
different thing depending on who's looking at it, they can interpret
it how they want and they do something. So I was like, oh yeah,
I do have these
[laughter] right now.
>> I'm also typing the first thing if I say oh well I have
this separate court case. Oh well maybe that's an improbable
cause to take my ship and I got to stay here and wait for them
to jerk off my before they bring it back to me. The second thing
is I've deleted it. Can I just Hello. Can I do you want me to
just explain it as I'm explaining right now or the second thing
I say? Oh, no. I don't have any of this. And then the next day,
because all of you guys are spamming Joan Peters, Joan sends
an email to my team saying, "Hey, we're going to file for a motion
claim exfoliation and adversary ruling because you're uh um the
defendant in this case is deleting all the videos that he said
that he's received or sent to Rose." And some of those might
be videos from Pixie. So, I would never say that publicly. At
this point, I don't really care because we're this deep into
it and they're not going to [__] [__]
out. But yeah, if I say, "Oh, no. I deleted every single thing
that I've sent or received." It's not stupid, Die. All of this
stuff has shown up in motions before. You can pretend it's not,
but you just [__] idiot.
I'm not a [__] idiot, which is why I'm not worried
about the FBI coming to my house.
I'd like to respond is criminal or anything despite what you
guys think. How many [__] phone calls you made to
the FBI on the first name basy?
I want to hear from Doobie. Doobie. Okay. So, okay. >> What
other claims do you have that you think are related to this?
>> So, I want to focus I want to focus on this one cuz
he just lied. >> Okay. Go ahead. >> So, I don't know.
I think you're aware of the Willy Mac stuff, are you? Wick >> vaguely.
Yes. The Will. >> I don't follow like I I honestly I don't
follow much of this, right? But I'm I'm aware. Got it. So he's
as he's asked that explicitly in those
keep going.
Just let me finish his statement then he will find it. What do
you mean we will show it? Okay. As long as he addresses afterwards
when he said
let let him finish and then he can address it. Christ remember
that
>> 5year-olds? What are you talking about? >> When
you told your Discord you said I dropped to 5-year-olds. That's
why you're so sensitive about all these gun to five. >> Yeah.
When you No, you said you did. You admitted to it. You were bragging
about your years ago. This is why you're so obsessed about the
whole thing. Make sure totally fine to make up. Go for it. Hold
on. So Wickb
you want to address me? Go ahead, Duby.
>> For a second. So if you look at the DMC with Will as
[clears throat] Oh, it's so crazy that shows this kind of stuff
as a minor, right? Like a like a portion of a clip. It shows
like the VLC player in the title of the clip. >> Um then
Will says something like, "Oh, do you still have this? I mean,
you just told me that you potentially have like C and he says
yes." Like three times. So
yeah, I'll get it for you. So then he justifies by saying oh
I can explain this after you might think that I don't know why
which is stupid. Um I don't think I don't think any any lawyer
would tell you to hold on to right and you know at the time you
you know for a year almost here at that point >> you know
that a lawyer telling you to delete stuff
you know a lawyer would
turn it over to the police because what you have
>> it's so funny how transparent you think >> like
we all see what he's doing right anytime Dubie is making a point
D has to start spuring in the middle of it. >> You want
to hear something like Yeah. You're distract you're distracting
from what I'm saying cuz you're like >> I'm not distracting
at all. By the way, Wick, I sent you the look that anything was
said. Go ahead. 5-year-old. >> Yeah. Tell us what. Yeah.
Go ahead. >> Okay. Great. So, so
way in the future when I quote this conversation, we're say,
"Do we agree that he did 5-year-old?" >> Yeah. Shut up
for a second. That's fine. Shut up for a bit. Okay. So, what
they would typically say is obviously I don't think we tell you
to hold on to Case. They'd probably tell you to turn to turn
it over to the police with their help, right? I don't think anybody
would tell you to hold on to >> No, but they also won't
tell you. They might have told you to hold,000
million. There is not a single lawyer in the universe who would
say, "Oh, that illegal stuff that you have, you should go and
take that to the police telling them that you have it." You think
a lawyer would tell you to do that [laughter] to me? >> Okay,
just real quick, we have we have the law. >> I mean that
you've been sent and is public record at this point. >> Hold
on. Just real quick.
a a lawyer would help would say go to the police turn >> over
given given again given at the time you did not know it was ceasing
and I accept that I'm not saying you knew you were dropped off
to a 17-year-old right but or potentially younger right so I
think they would help you organize with with them to turn it
over to the police and say hey I might have some evidence of
a child being trafficked here it is >> okay reasonable
thing to do >> yeah just FYI we do have the logs >> hold
on we do have the logs that um uh Willie Mack posted uh the DMs
between Willie Mack and Destiny I did I do have them up on uh
screen. Um Doobie. Uh >> Where in this should I be looking
to see him saying that he has cam on his
>> Okay. So, if you look at the
So, he says that's just absolutely insane to think that he was
him doing all this uh issue 17. And um then Willie Mack asks,
"If you're sending me this, I'm guessing you still have that
video." He says, "It depends what you're asking." And he says,
"But yes, I created a copy blah blah blah blah." Then he goes
to then uh Willie Mack asked him again, right? So I think he
says, "Oh, you just uh um where is it, >> bro? There's
been allegations at least my last vid that she was underageed
>> and you still have potential CP of her." >> Yeah.
Is there's an obligation to preserve it? Blah blah blah blah
blah. >> To preserve [laughter] what? To preserve it. To
preserve childpoint. Is that what I said? >> Preserve relevant
evant
evidence. There >> no you literally said you had the video
and then you sent the video file. You sent the picture of the
video. You Hold on. In this in this >> he literally said
he had the file. He said he had the video and then he said a
screenshot of the video that was shot when she was 17. >> In
this exchange, weren't you justifying holding on to that video?
>> Did I send Did I send Willie Mac a video of childborn?
>> Okay, you're being stupid. So, in this
um a video and justify holding on hold on to justify holding
on to that video that you said that you have. Um you you said
you were holding on to your like I'm just checking. Did I send
Did I send >> So obviously obviously So obviously you were
referring to that specific video that you said you had when when
he asked you about it. You weren't referring to something else,
were you? >> What? Wait, what if I was referring to a screenshot
that I made?
>> He asked you about the video.
>> What if I referring I'm guessing you still have that
and you said yes. What if you're like a what if you're a complete
and lying to him or us? I mean, I feel like you're lying now.
>> Um, what if I'm No, I didn't say yes. I said, um, depends
on why you're asking what's emote. But yes, >> I could
have copied his messages and everything when that court case.
>> But yes, but yes, he's like explicitly trying not to
read the messages. >> Yes. What does you mean by but yes,
what does that mean to you? >> For on which part? >> Uh
it's the right uh says Destiny says but yes, I created a copy
of all of our messages and everything that started. Do you think
that they can help us? Do you think I can help? What was the
question? Let Let Destiny Let Destiny finish his point then I
will answer your question. Do we go ahead? So, do is it do you
think that I have 61 gigabytes of child port on my computer or
a single gigabyte of child my computer or everything that she
sent me that screen?
>> No, I think the screen was going around was like I think
you said it was a screenshot of her like sash that she showed
you and I believe you don't have all that right. I'm not accusing
you of holding on to I think you're holding on to that because
you're probably trying to look for some some way to find her.
>> Okay, Dy, you wanted to ask a So, you think I have
what was Go ahead Doobie, please. >> Wait, to be clear,
what was the question he was asked before he said but yes, cuz
his claim remember was where did I say yes? So, Willie Mack at
11:19 a.m. says, "If you are sending me this, I'm guessing you
still have that video."
And then say, "Uh, depends on what you're asking." But yes, I
created a copy of all of our messages and everything when that
court case started. >> What do you mean by everything?
Wait, what do you mean by everything, Destiny? Do you mean like
everything but the video that I'm saying? Yes, I have a copy
of that video. Is that what you meant when you said, "But yes,
I made a copy of everything." You meant everything but the thing
you were saying yes to explicitly.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. So, it seems pretty clear. You said, "Yes,
we do have that
>> Okay. And if that's the case, then
you saw that video. >> The issue The issue is that you're
trying to parse
>> messages in the most strict manner, like implying that
I'm sending these messages as though they're about to be gone
through by every single person on the >> No, I'm not doing
that at all.
>> You say, "No, I don't I don't have it." >> Why
would I tell somebody that Doobie when I'm
injustice? >> Yes. Destiny, finish your point. So, they've
already threatened to file multiple motions, which they never
did, did by the way, cuz all it was a [__] lie, of
evidence of expoliation, saying that I'm deleting evidence, saying
that I'm hiding [__] Why the would I start telling
people privately, "Oh, I'm deleting stuff. Oh, I'm hiding stuff.
Oh, I'm deleting." Why would I ever put that in a written message
anyway? >> I'm not I'm not saying you should have done
that. What I'm saying is that what I I think >> you just
said that. You just said that. Oh, no. I deleted that video anyway.
Why would I ever put that in a message? >> No. No, no,
no. You could have just said, "Hey, no, I turned it over." I
mean, in a in the idea, >> hey, no, you just said I didn't
say no. We're not done. Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. in the idea
what we had done is said hey no I turned it over to the police
with my lawyer and let them know that hey this is potentially
evidence of child sex trafficking that's I think that's what
the the bizarro destiny in the good world will do instead you
said you do have [laughter] is this literally already part of
my first court case haven't I done all of this stuff already
haven't I already publicly said I've done all of this stuff already
>> no I think at the time you I think the >> no I
think I have said all of it I think literally all of this
every single
minor you were told she was a minor like a year >> doesn't
matter it doesn't
you know for a year the least trust And literally all of us so
unrest that even was born of this girl as well. Number one number
two
whether or not she's a minor. It really doesn't matter. There
was already a crime committed. I was already in contact with
people in order to get this turned over as a crime. Really regardless
of whether or not she was a minor. There was already a crank
>> No, we're caught up finally pursue the trafficking case.
>> Number two. Yeah, I'd like to. Yeah, maybe. I mean it
depends on
>> so so Destiny says IFC Sam because when I originally
found out somebody told me hey when you go through those logs
the logs that were leaked you can go through them and find basically
a name that goes to a Twitter profile where that person was selling
somebody sent me a picture of her face cropped just to her face
only and said look this is her and I was like oh that's crazy
and so the solo guy had been messaging me and I said hey just
so you know you didn't crop this you didn't like hide this person's
information very well. I expect they're probably going to get
doxed because if I if someone in my group could find it, then
probably everybody's going to find it. You should tell her to
clear her online presence to to like go and scrub her online
presence cuz she's probably going to get doxed.
And then Solo followed that up with, "Well, actually, that's
you just sent me a crop photo of" and I was like, "Well, that's
weird that you say that now, but guess what I did when I heard
that? I deleted that immediately even though it wasn't I was
like, "Oh, well, I'm not keeping that around that." >> You
like to or you are. Are you doing that? Are you doing that currently?
>> I can't do anything regarding that until this current
court case is over. >> So, okay. So, to be clear, when
I said
they hold
a year after one time. One time. One time. I know you all want
to go. Hold on. I know you all want to go. Stop. Please. So this
is so if Duby wants to hyper obsess over like single lines in
I'm just trying to hold the lies that you're telling you think
>> I tossed so it was a picture a picture that I didn't
know was from a picture even less and I immediately deleted the
image that had no child imagery in it whatsoever a picture of
her face cuz I was told that that hey she's underage actually
and that's like a picture of her that's like images like oh well
>> zero evidence that I have child on my computer okay
you have nothing
that I'm sending message I'm sending
you online that I have no idea that people are going to be going
through line by line to try to ascertain if I have child
>> he triples down on that he kept the file right computer
which is considering I'm one in an active court he's litigating
this and two I know I've got 50 billion people calling FM constantly
beyond. And three, how the have I not been in that context makes
sense on your computer? >> Just to be clear, I never had
any of that. Just to be clear, never had any of that on my computer.
Never had it in my Discord logs, nothing like that. >> How
does How does that make any sense? >> What in the context?
Yeah. So, the
Hold on, just real quick, let me explain what he means because
I want to know what he means. He doesn't like the fact that the
reason that's not true. I'm trying to I'm trying to get to
>> There's no way he did it again. He didn't do it again,
did he? He didn't. He didn't do it again.
>> Oh my god. >> He really wants to call the FBI
and say
I don't give a [__] I know that I know that I'm in
the right for everything and I know I'm not [__]
child. I have no problem with any of that. However, if I start
saying that I've deleted it, then the other party can start filing
more motions against me because they've already we got to let
Dubie respond. Doobie, go ahead. Please. Like like do you think
it's more or less likely they're going to file motions if you
say that you have child porn or that you turn that child over
to the police? I feel like if you tell them, hey, no, I don't
have child I turn it over. >> What motions would they file
against me if I say I have child porn? What are you talking about?
>> Then okay, then why why are you saying that they might
file motions against you if you say I've deleted a bunch of deleted
or got rid of it or turned it over to the police? No, I'm not
saying you could say, "Hey, I turned it over to the police from
malware." Right. And that's potential evidence of child sex
>> Like that seems like a norainer. >> I don't have
any more. I have an obligation to preserve stuff that is relevant
to my court case. If that somebody have deleted stuff, then they
can file a motion disposal. >> The child portionally for
Destiny is relevant to his court case because it's like how it
leaked, right? Was the person who >> Okay. So, you are
saying that if your case didn't involve, you'd have an obligation
to hold on to the CM.
>> If I don't know if there would be a civil case involving
childhood material. >> Yeah, that's not what I'm asking
you. I'm asking if your case involved like actual CISM, you're
telling me that you believe you'd have an obligation to hold
on to CM personally. >> I don't know the obligation at
that point. It probably really weird. >> Okay, then why
the say that? Cuz you're here justifying holding on to CSM. I'm
not I don't understand how you Yes, you are obligated whether
we're not let
the issue is not
>> I feel like probably this clip should get like sort
of just totally blown up and people should be I think I think
people need to clip this like absolutely >> whether or
not I'm holding on to something the issue whether or not I say
I've deleted stuff I can delete it and say yeah
I can say nobody should say that I don't know how much time the
>> You're going to be able to respond, Destiny. You are
going to be able to respond uninterrupted to be clear.
>> Yeah, because he knows turn this over to the police
cuz potentially evidence of a >> Let me know, Wick. Let
me know as soon as I'm not saying, "Hey, you should say, hey,
I deleted all
>> Jesus Christ." >> Okay, he ded himself like a
So, so Wick, to be clear for people in chat, right, I'm not saying
he should have deleted everything or said he deleted anything.
I think if you have evidence potentially of and child trafficking,
you should turn that over to the police. I I think that any reasonable
person would do >> And he said he's never turned it over
to the police after they found out her age. Right. This is what
Ellie B asked him and he said, "No, I've never turned over I
I've never talked to the police cuz um cuz I totally thought
she was above 18 this guys." >> I think he was told this
this girl was potentially underage over a year prior to this
and he held on to it for a year and then justified it. Right.
So him saying now >> that uh actually uh I had to say that
I it made it made the most sense to say that I have the child
sex trafficking I'm sorry on my computer almost a year after
being told that it was
that doesn't make like how is that less likely to cause him trouble
and saying hey no the [__] police. >> Yeah
we're going to let him answer.
Well, hold on. Wick, can you please just show the show the messages?
He's just lying about what's >> Wait, am I allowed to But
I mean, but I mean, click on them and actually zoom in so we
can see allowed to speak yet or probably pretty small. >> No,
I'm still not allowed to speak. >> No, you're you're go
ahead. Can I I'll just queue a game and go play when he's done
yapping. Okay, you can say that you've deleted bad stuff. The
whole point about you deleting stuff for a civil court case is
that the other party doesn't know what you've deleted. So if
I say I deleted a bunch of stuff, all they have to do is file
a motion claiming expoliation and saying, "Oh, well, he's actually
deleting stuff that's relevant." >> Yeah, that's exactly
the bind Destiny is in is
>> the case. Those were actually all videos of Pixie that
he's saying. And now I have no ability to prove that if I've
already said this, if I have an ambiguous position on it and
they try to follow, oh, you have no evidence that I'm hiding
it. You have no evidence of deleting anything. But if I want
to say this publicly, I'm begging for them to get an adversarial
reading on expiliation. That's why. And this is these are motions
already filed or not. >> I'm not saying I'm not saying
I'm not saying you should have said he deleted it or that you
should have deleted it. I'm saying you should have probably turned
it over to the police as evidence >> you're speaking Redditisms
that don't make sense. When you say, what does it mean to turn
it over to police if not to delete it from your computer? >> Okay,
but he said he didn't go to the >> No, hold on. If you
turn it over to the police, the police, it doesn't like disappear.
They have a copy of it. So the court needs >> how are they
gonna get how are they going to go to the police and get copies
of the police
hold you're so you're saying it would be unfathomable for me
to if it's you can't hold that for a court case blah blah blah
which I agree is is legally dubious at best but you're saying
that they could go to the police and ask for copies of child
>> I'm saying if it's relevant to the case yes I'm sure
the court has some way to access it or ask
>> uh it wouldn't be the child it would be like the record
of what was deleted from these conversations right like hey I
have these files you'd probably go to your lawyer and say hey
I have these files here are the file references I'm I need to
delete this but it needs to not be spoliated for my court case.
>> Not the court party
you have no idea what you're talking about. How about I go with
the two different law firms I'm talking >> so Destiny's
going to hyperbolize his claim here and then spur a whole bunch
right but that's not what Doobie claimed Destiny's just making
up Dubby's trying to say there's like some way we could actually
do this so you wouldn't get in your court case but you didn't
even attempt it. You've said you haven't gone to the police advising
me on what to do. I never said that at all. I never said that
at all. I said that I'm doing exactly what they tell you. >> My
oblig I'm not gonna It's called
these two law firms. Did did they or did they not tell you to
hold on to CM because that's what you're advised me on the proper
route to take with regards to this material and I'm listening
to their advice. One of those is to hold on to the CM. >> I'm
not going to break my confidentiality for a random [__]
>> What you're saying what you're saying is that they apparently
advise you to hold on to the [__] CM which is >> Oh,
is that what I'm saying? Is that really? Yes.
Make copies of it so that none of it degrades. So that's again
just go to the transcript of what was being said here when when
Mack asked repeatedly that video like the video you held on to
that you're saying your lawyer told you to hold hold on to that
and Desi goes yeah
24/7 I'm actually recording those copies I gave him more copies
and I've got deep fake copies I got 20 million different copies
yeah right next to all the 5-year-old child that you collect
on your computer that's right you're so smart okay maybe maybe
we should move on to the next claim
he said that I got the director right at be honest about this
be about [__] anything. It's so straightforward,
right? You can't divulge every single
expensive civil case about how we trust you literally a single
you guys have been shown to have been lying about basically every
single thing that you've said. Almost everything you said has
been liaby.
She was caught lying about like 10 different things like every
single thing you guys have claimed about this. >> He just
made up a whole bunch of things that nobody has been wronged
thinking of losing it. There are no 15 women. There are no crazy
witnesses. Abuck
everything [__] lie. It's all not true. And then
the maximum in three
dismissed. You're not calling the case but you seem to know my
specific vlogs and I'm so convenient. You guys know everything.
I know that you don't know anything. You lie about
freak out and you associated with
all this kind of I'm not related to this at all. When did I talk?
That was the first time you made. Can you admit that was a lie?
You just made that up. Or can you show me where that happened?
>> No, I think I think you went to uh her um I think the
[clears throat] place where she works. You pulled out your >> I
went to the place where she Where does she work? >> I think
she says it on video. Actually, I'm going to post it for you.
Okay.
I'll send it to you. >> Don't go to the door. >> How
can I go where she I don't even know where she works. >> This
is on 1.25 cuz I'm trying to >> find out.
I don't >> Yeah, hold on.
>> One by one yard of >> I feel like this is this
is the worst thing for Dubie to go in on is any of the Lauren
de Laguna stuff. He just needs to keep going.
>> SK fans couldn't go to them try to look >> Wait,
is Sixth Street the most popular street in all of Texas? I have
no idea. It's the most question. Okay. So,
showing up to me phone. She ran up to me with her phone out,
right? >> You just happen to be there. Yeah. >> I
just happen to be on the most popular street there. I've been
there multiple times before. I've streamed on that stream before.
Do you know that? >> Okay, that's fine. So, again, if you
want those things, do you know that I've been on before? >> I
don't know where the [__] you've been. >> you
know that I've been on street >> I follow street. >> You
know that I was on the street? Why did you follow this? >> You
[laughter] posted on [__] >> Okay. Twitter
post
>> Twitter. The stupid.
So, Sixth Street is the most popular street in the city of Austin.
Probably is the most popular street in the entirety of Texas.
So, if I've been there before, I've streamed there before. Lots
of people go there. There were multiple people on that street
that recognized me. It's a very popular street. And she ran up
to me and my friend to start recording us, although I found out
later. It was actually she was on FaceTime with somebody. She
ran up to us. How was that on me? >> Okay, if that's your
line, >> how was that on me? I don't I don't I don't believe
you. >> How was that on me? What? Oh, so what do you think
happened again? >> No, then explain what you I think you
probably went I probably I think you probably went there to [__]
with her.
>> how did I pull her out into the street to with her?
>> I'm not saying I'm not saying you pulled out into the
street. >> Then why was she out on the side? Why was she
on the street a chance to to tell us exactly what he means by
[__] with her? Cuz I'm I'm really curious what he
mean. >> Yeah, tell us.
>> Yeah, I think you probably went there to uh let her
see you so she'd freak the out so you could show her on Twitter
and get your fans to go over there with her like you've had it
done with other >> And what is your evidence of this?
your behavior. Not in just this situation, but other situations.
>> My behavior. Why you you're not answering the question
at all? Your
>> Yeah. Your behavior. Your behavior. >> Well, to
be clear, dude is saying that you his claim is you've done things.
>> Yeah. But he has no evidence of me. Do you know that
I before this, by the way, have evidence of Lauren being on a
podcast literally just saying my full address down to the apartment?
>> I don't support it. I don't think that if she did that
number that justifies what you did. >> Okay. And then you
know that I'm visiting I'm in the most popular street in all
of Austin and she's running up to me screaming at me like a crazy
person. I had no I didn't even know she was in the state. >> I
thought she >> Yeah, you should never I'm sorry. It's just
fighting on the Lauren de Laguna stuff. It's just now >> she
live here in Florida. I didn't even know she to Texas.
>> Did not believe me. And I have every piece of evidence
that >> Wait, did he not I'm pretty sure he knew she was
moving to Texas cuz he covered the Action Man stuff. Didn't he
tweet about the Action Man stuff? Isn't that a lie? that Lauren
is lying
there
right now. You can ask her right now. You can ask for approach
who first on the street because in deposition Lauren said, "Oh,
well, I went up to him with his friend on the street. Would it
be difficult for you to show up on the street or show up in front
of a business should go into the building and let her see you
so she could freak the out and run outside to to confront you?"
>> So, I'm not allowed. So, first of all, you're assuming
that I know she lives in Texas, which I don't. You have no proof
of that because I didn't know she lived in Texas. Number one.
Number two, you assume that you're asking where she's working
at in Austin or whatever the I don't even know that. I still
don't even know what she works. I think somebody said maybe the
mothership. I don't even know if that's true. Number two. Number
three. You're saying that just by me walking by on six, I'm not
allowed to do that anymore if she's working.
>> Again, I get it. This your line. >> Am [laughter]
I not allowed to walk down the streets
on any business? I do not believe you. I think you probably
have nothing. How you're saying? You're saying I can't be believed
on anything. These are the tales that you guys are >> No,
you stupid. I just demonstrated that you're a liar. >> Demonstrate
anything about anything.
Okay, I guess we have to go through it again. She was screaming.
But yes, you have that video. So when you told me earlier, you
never said you had it, but you never said you had
single lines from conversation because you guys will ever have.
And that's great. I've got child my computer
going to come down. They're going to bust my doors out and everything
else. And I got you
just real quick. Just real quick. Hold on. CP versus [__]
like
both of you. Shut up. Hold on. Instead of Dusty saying, "No,
I don't have it." He provides multiple reasons why he's retained
it, right? Like he's he's he provides multiple reasons. Hey,
why do you sell that CP? Multiple reasons why he retained it.
Just stick to the Willy M. Uh, I do. Doobie did ask you a direct
question, Destiny, and I have made him answer your direct question.
So, I'm going to make you answer his. Did you when you said,
"But yes." Was that a
>> I don't know if I would call it a lie. I'm not like
I'm not having a conversation where I'm expecting the text to
be parsed for 100% accuracy on like you would ask me like, "Hey,
did you go out to eat McDonald's last week or whatever?" I'm
like, "Yeah, I love McDonald's. I probably a couple times." But
you actually you roll back the calendar like, "Actually, you
haven't gone since 3 weeks ago." Like, [__] me. Am
I a liar? I didn't know we were going to be going through the
the line by line. You go and see the the testimony that I've
made in court or you can see the filings that I've been in court
like what like I don't know how >> you let me finish though
right so if you want to parse every single message well you said
all of it right here
I didn't know if you think you think I ch on my computer >> currently
no the time yes >> okay if that's what you think there's
nothing there's no way that I can I can prove that >> but
I think because you said you had it like I don't you said it
so like yeah >> I said that I did everything I needed to
do I backed up all the messages everything I need
I'm doing everything I need to do in compliance with my court
case >> dude okay >> right now the civil video for
me with so when I'm speaking to anybody in any DM cuz I don't
know what'll show up in discovery. I am speaking to maximize
for my civil >> That's fine. >> Okay. So you said
Okay. So you said you had the video which you thought was Cam,
>> But if that's how you want to interpret it, then go
for it. Listen, it'll show up somewhere. It'll show it'll show
up >> Okay. Are we ready to go to the Darius >> Yeah,
we can go to it. >> No, I want him to admit first that
he has no evidence of the lore and stuff and all the other evidence
points to the contrary. We'll get there. stalked me and my friend
on the street. She ran up and started screaming. She started
recording. She had no reason to be on the street. And >> uh
Doobie, don't let him spur. Just go. You got to ask about >> Die
story that I somehow knew she he totally That's why Desi was
spering so hard because Destiny wanted to not get to this screenshot
of when Willie Mack explicitly says, "You still have that's crazy.
It's so and then Destiny instead of saying no, I don't have it."
He literally just justifies it repeatedly.
This is so obvious, right? Lived there, that I knew she worked
there, that I showed up there, and that me just simply being
on the street is justification for her to come out screaming
at me. Why wouldn't she take a picture first? Why wouldn't she
tell a friend or contact anybody else or any proof whatsoever?
Notice how she didn't do any of that, right? That would have
been a really easy thing to do. Just so I can ask Dubie directly,
Dubie, do you have evidence that Destiny knew or suspected that
Lauren Deagona either lived there or worked there at Sixth Street?
>> No. No evidence. Okay. >> But but again, this
this belief that I have that he went there probably to [__]
with her and other people to [__] with her. Just
based on his behavior, right? >> You know that there was
a there was a political conference in that very city that I was
attending that day, right? Is that a coincidence? >> Uh,
no. I don't think it's a coincidence >> Okay. So, do you
think I was just at that conference? Maybe. Yeah, I'm sure you're
at the conference. So like if you >> But I used it as a
double opportunity to go to a six week.
You're like I'm stuck on when you lie. Yeah, when you lie it's
like really annoying. That's what you want to call again given
the the lie you just told a little bit ago. I think you're >> the
lie that I told that I didn't type with 100% accuracy to represent
the entire context of my archives. >> Yes, you had this
video and then just just a bit ago you said you didn't say you
had the video. >> You know what? If you want to be honest,
if you want to go through I just told a lie to Wick cuz when
I meet him before I said I was going to queue a game of Arc Raiders
until I could get to speak. I didn't actually quue a game. So
that was another lie. Apparently I
go ahead. >> So to be clear, so not not a long time ago.
So a little bit ago when you said that you never said you had
that video, you said you never said that, right? And then we
went we looked at the logs and you did say that you had it. So
you like >> No, I said that I'm if you if anybody who's
not reads the messages, it's very obvious that what I'm saying
is I have kept everything that I need to keep in compliance with
my court case. I think even in that same message I say that I
have maintained every record that I need to keep. I'm in a company.
>> One of those things you thought you needed to keep was
that video, right? Because you said but yes. >> I don't
think I have an obligation to keep child. >> Why did you
say but yes then? Why did you say but? YES. >> BECAUSE
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT ANYTHING THE FBI SEES BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE
CHILD. I AM WORRIED ABOUT WHAT SHOWS UP IN CIVIL litigation because
Joan can file more motions at me.
right about a potential case coming from the child sex trafficking.
Right. You just came up with that for no reason. cuz you >> potential
case. What are you talking >> Oh, sorry. I am a little
behind. My bad. My bad. My bad. >> What do you mean? What?
>> Okay. So, I I guess I'll send you that. It wasn't in
the screen put up earlier like I'll send a video. >> Okay.
Do you want me to
join a case against me? You talking >> Hold on. Give me
a second. Let me >> This is what you're like >> like
the title of the video and like a little bit of the top of the
video. >> So, just to read this for people who might not
be able to. Willie Max says, "Buh, talk to a lawyer. That seems
crazy to me. Bro, you just let me know. You still have videos
saved to your computer. You knew it was alleged that she was
underage. You still have them. Do you see how this is? Destiny
says, "One, I don't even know 100% if her age is legitimately
less than 18 when these were taken. Two, I'm pretty sure I still
have an obligation to preserve stuff related to my court case.
I've talked about this with my lawyer already, specifically with
regards to the Rose stuff. Three, if something were to come out
of this, I don't know, I'd want to wipe everything and not have
something to turn over to authorities. If hypothetically her
boyfriend or whatever was actually trafficking her or getting
her to other dudes on video for him, and if there was ever some
kind of investigation into that, am I hurting any chance of looking
into him by deleting all of this stuff? >> Like, to me,
that looks like a numbered list of why you had on to right or
something you thought might potentially be a >> cool. So,
if that looks like it to you, then that's fine. But you're just
>> Well, what's the explanation? Like that's I think it's
pretty. I mean, wait, do you >> I've already given the
explanation like Wait, can you play back the record? Wait, what
was the explanation I gave 20 >> The explanation that uh
Destiny gave 20 times was that uh according to Destiny, he didn't
think that this was going to be parsed. So, he spoke in generalities
that he didn't think were going to be >> But what is the
what is the one? >> Wait, wait, wait. If it's not going
to be parsed, why would you just say I don't have C that I
respond? You were worried about civil litigation. And you were
worried about blowback in civilization civilitig Correct. And
in civil litigation, I have an obligation to preserve anything
that might be related to my case. So any messages that I send,
anything that I talk about is maximizing for that civil litigation
because
>> I don't have child you. I have a kid. Do you think if
I actually had child even at the point when I'm talking to Willie,
do you think I'd be saying like, "Oh, well, I think it's important
for me to hold on to the child." Do you really think I would
say that? >> I'd hope not, but you did. I'd hope not, but
you did.
video that at the time you seem like you thought was was he Sam
you were asking
why he's got so much server
ask questions about pedophilia
why you talk about a few years ago that's cool I give my explanation
you literally believe all these things without evidence that
I collaborated >> I am belieing
so Yeah, you got it. >> So, I don't I don't know why you
you thought it was like useful to say that you're holding on
to >> Wait, hold on. I think Cell is knocking at my door
right now. Oh, >> oh god. >> Okay, one more thing
cuz this is boring. Give me the next the strongest next piece
of evidence or whatever. >> Also, wait, just checking real
quick. The rile kitten house guy, he was doxing people, too,
wasn't he? Was that the >> Do you have any evidence of
that? >> If I showed you evidence, would you
acknowledge that?
>> I didn't. Yeah, if you showed me evidence of him doxing
people, I'd acknowledge he was doxing people. Yeah. So far as
I'm aware, he was not. Do you have evidence? So, after um here
you go, Wick. So, after I doxed um the written house dude, uh
I think he bounced for a little bit before he came back uh to
the server. Here's some of the things that people were saying
about him. I don't have all of this off hand because I don't
usually argue with this. Also, because it's a waste of time arguing
with people like do you because they're not going to believe
anything that doesn't fit their narrative anyway, but people
knew that he was a doc and just
this is about Riyle getting drunk one night and like threatening
some guy and being like, I can look anything up about you and
then the next morning being hung over and being like, that's
what this is about. Didn't do cyclone. The guy is >> I
also don't think he doxed the cyclone >> Oh says I don't
think he has doxed
>> Uh
just I can over whether this [__] is ass. What is
Stacey? Um
>> yeah Ry got like giga drunk and I think he kind of implied
that he would do that but again this is like people getting impetty
personal beef on the internet. He's not doxing like critics.
He's not like systemically doxing people who talk about him.
Right. That's pretty sure he >> Stacey says if you do someone
slur in a hard slur down syndrome should die. >> Why didn't
R deny it here when people said it to him? Um I don't know why
JTOK is so hellbent on keeping certain people in the server.
Cough cough Chris let us uh I don't know kind of why I wish Jtok
would take a harder stance on issues involving doxing and harassment.
Then again he didn't really care about >> this is this
is this is virtue. Ralph is being sarcastic here by the way.
That's he's reading until stuff came out about Cherry. So, and
then Shell Bonner says, "I forgot about this and relationship
to the didn't Riyle dox cyclone." And Shel Boner says, "Apparently
Ry said Kelly, Yoj, and me should all and RPed or something."
Uh, and that's what it says. >> Okay. So, so clear you
have no evidence of doxing anybody, right? >> Um, people
knew that he doxed people. I don't have any evidence right now.
I go maybe dug for it, but just to go wipe all of his Discord
servers logs like
>> I didn't wipe any of the logs. They're all still just
sitting there. In fact, Destiny should probably know this. August
had actually had access to those logs up until like yesterday.
August had access to those logs the entire time.
So, I don't know if maybe August didn't share them with him,
but August had access to those logs as of yesterday. >> Okay.
The Cyclone guy or whatever, I guess. And the other people as
well, but I have more evidence of this than you have of me stalking
this. You feel like you knew about it. Okay. Yeah, we can go
to the the Dar. >> Okay. Give me one second. What? You
sent me two videos on this. Which one do you want me to watch?
>> Yeah. So, so one is Darius. Pick the best one cuz [__]
pick the strongest one he's got. >> Is Dar Okay. Is Darius
going to [__] with Lauren? Uh, the one before that
is Darius going to [__] with this ra guy. I think
you should play both of them >> Okay, we'll just do it
in the order you sent me. I'm about to leave. What do you >> Hey,
I was just wondering if there's anything else you need me to
do to Lauren. I know you like sent me down. >> Why would
you even joke about it? I haven't done any of this. I don't even
joke about this on stream. Why would you say this? >> I'm
joking. I'm joking. >> This is going to end. No. Way to
go. >> Yeah. Apparently, he might have
Dude, I think he might have posted a secondary username for the
guy possibly.
Um, and again, incredibly cringe behavior that he apologized
for. Uh, he was like threatening the guy. It was It was cringe.
He was super drunk. >> Got 20 more filings. >> It
was a bad moment. >> Yeah. So, like, am I supposed to like
like how am I supposed to This person's on the street and they
like a pants like a promoter. Like I'm not trying >> you
guys have anything related to do with
I have like why like she sent me a bunch of messages afterwards
that were like Stephen sent you to do this like blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah like like how am I supposed to like >> I
don't know live your life you're a big boy you're an adult figure
out what to do but send me those what you said but
>> okay what's
I send it to you in like reverse order. So the first one [laughter]
you should have watched was the was the most recent one. >> Uh
okay >> that's after that's after he [__] I
didn't know. Hold on. This is tone sign to it's a tone indicator
right? He has to laugh cuz I think Doobie is probably going to
make like a good point. >> This is a debate. I didn't know
reality stone. Okay, I can't win this one. If this is it, if
reality is whatever we want it to be, then I mean clearly I've
lost, I guess. My bad.
>> Hold on. Uh I'm trying to Do you have like a link to
this uh one? I don't want to show my Discord logs. >> Um
I Let me see if I can find one for >> Yeah, please do.
>> Can you just play like So if I want to just download
the file then play >> I just full screen here. I figured
out. >> Yeah, that's that works. >> I'm I'm mean
to everybody though. That's my thing. I'm like mean and like
full.
>> But it's like a bad boy thing.
>> How have you been? >> I'm bar.
>> You live here now?
>> Do you like it?
>> I'm not a big fan. >> It's like a lot. >> And
it's also like >> they don't allow weed here and stuff,
so I have to like go to like >> Oh, hold on.
>> Hello. What are we doing here? Uh, Pacquiao, thank you
for the five gift,
>> GHCA is
>> and live. >> Okay, so appropriate for him to go
go to [__] with her on the stream after you like
show her where she lives or whatever. I'm so works. >> Do
you think it was appropriate for Lauren to run up and scream
at me and my friend and chase us down the street with a phone
recording and accusing me of being a pedophile? >> I don't
know. She accuse you of being a I don't agree with. >> Didn't
she literally say that in one of the videos I posted? She was
like >> did call him a >> Now that I'm aware but
but again I don't >> she did. It's crazy how you're so
aware of everything except for the things it got against you.
>> Wait, is Destiny claiming that calling somebody a was
wrong? >> Always crazy how your community >> I I
don't Hold on. Whether or not I should call it doesn't really
>> This is like the new game they play. Is Destiny applies
moral standards to other people that he never applies to himself
and that DG never holds up to >> affect my claim at all.
Like I don't it's irrelevant.
Let's assume that what Darius just did, let's say that that was
inappropriate. What behavior was worse? Lauren running up to
me and a friend on the street with her phone out screaming at
me
when I have no desire or will or anything to do anything related
to her. >> I know, but again, I know what you're saying,
but I >> or Dar screaming and walking up to her on the
street where she given what we just went over, which proves that
you're a liar. I don't believe that you didn't go with there
to [__] with her, right? >> how I there was
a there was a political conference that was literally there that
I literally attended. >> Okay. So, you go to this political
conference that you're there for >> and because you're
in the area and you know Lauren works here, you go to [__]
with her. Like that's >> this is not like a situation in
downtown
and again giving her the behavior.
Not only doxing people, encouraging people to dox people and
then encouraging them to [__] with them. >> So,
look, I sent you a couple more screenshots. Wait, no, no. You
understand that if you go to downtown Austin
behavior
doxing and harassing people, if you go this is and this is honestly
this is the point. So I'll do this and then I'm pointless,
right?
So that I'm just saying that like his evidence of harassment
and doxing is one a claim from Lauren he has absolutely zero
evidence of and I can show you I can literally link I the friend
that I was with Lauren Southern was literally participating at
a political conference. I you can go look at the schedule. I
was literally at her event. After the event, we went to Sixth
Street. It was literally like a few blocks away because in downtown
Austin, you go to Sixth Street to go drinking after you do events.
It's like the most famous street in the entire state of Texas.
Anybody who's ever been in Texas or in Austin knows this to be
the case. The fact that you would even say that you were on Sixth
Street afterward is the dumbest thing in the world. It shows
you have no concept of what's going on. Number one. Number two,
and then the my favorite thing is the counter examples of like,
well, this is my example of harassment is Darius walking up to
somebody on the on the sidewalk and then having a benign conversation
with them for a minute. And I think that that's like the >> wait
did they pull why didn't they just pull the rile clip of Darius
like going to his house and shouting like after Destiny that's
the that's the play here. Why are you doing Lauren de Laguna?
Why wouldn't you just go to the ri >> perfect encapsulation
that's the microcosm of this entire conversation and it's why
I have no sympathy for any
>> Okay. So I you don't give a [__] So, like
I said earlier, um my issue is that not only are you a liar,
but when you're caught in these lies, you can't just own up to
the lies. You take no accountability. For example, what you said
to Willie Mack, right? For example, what what I just said to
Wick. I mean, do you have some kind of justification for encouraging
people to dogs wicked supreme or me? Like, I don't or or >> anybody
that participates in your communities, I think that you guys
engage in harassment that rises to the level of or greater than
doxing, of >> Okay. Hey, so why should why shouldn't people
do people in your community then? >> They already I love
it. I love it. But you're saying you're saying [laughter] I love
when you guys do this thing where you're like
anybody you guys already do. Every single person around me is
already
literally posted people's addresses and
on stream. >> Okay, you stupid
your guys who have your community. Who have I doxed? Nobody,
right? And I'm not related to the [__] [__]
game of like spoken about ever posted dogs. Did I? Yeah, cuz
you're because you guys all do it. >> We're playing the
game of, you know,
the the western the the same justice system every western liberal
democracy has. You can only be punished for the things that could
be proven against you. Yeah. The game of liberalism.
I've never advocated for doxing anybody. >> I'm good. I'm
good on this one. >> I've never advocated for doxing anybody.
So, what you're saying is because bad empanada did a thing. Can
you show this? How many emails did this guy say that he sent
to uh where was his family? You can go ahead and post that. The
second one is uh Saba by the way. >> I know you said 18
then you said 27. I don't know what the exact number is. So again
so because bad empanada dox people right you show that one
second. >> There you go. >> And hold on. What makes
it reasonable to do wicket supreme? >> So J says to the
tough potato. How many of your emails were just informing Rose
you had a profile taken down with a dynamic she was consenting
to and happy to speak to you on? And they respond 17 out of 27
in the conversation were about that. Five were emails from her
to me. One was a forward from Joan. So that's the screenshot
you sent me.
>> So why is Destiny bringing that? Wait, why did Destiny
just bring up evidence that like works against >> that's
where he got the 187 27 from? That's reasonable. So again, but
your argument for the >> So Rose was talking back to him.
He just wrecked himself. He's speechless because he totally ripped
himself right there. is that it's it's justified to dox me because
bad empanada dox somebody in your community or like did wicked
supreme dox anybody? I don't think I've ever advocated to do
anybody unless it's like some reporting to the [__]
police. So like what what did I do? What did Wicked Supreme do
what eourse admin do to justify the doxing that you're encouraging?
Never ask me you're >> Hold on. Wait a second.
>> Was that supposed to support him?
>> Um in the meantime gang if uh you're liking this content
uh hit that like button, hit that subscribe button. So you know
here we are. I like if you could show those screenshots of the
site >> Yeah, give me a second. >> Great. So, I would
like to know the answer to that question. >> Give me one
second.
>> Also, why were you saying on on earlier I feel like
doc is a site where everyone on that website harasses people
and finds real life and sponsor host. What are you talking about?
>> No, I think is a site that's known for getting people.
I think that's
where people stuff and they find somebody who
I think I have a decent idea of what goes on that website. Thank
you. Okay. >> I'm sure I'm sure you do. But again, doc
people check. Everybody who's aware of Docman knows this. It's
pretty straightforward. I have the screenshot you wanted to show
uh wanted me to show to be what am I looking for here? You want
me to trade it out?
>> the highlighted part or
>> all of it? >> Okay. So, uh highlighted on uh November
17th, 2025, Destiny says, "Also, if anyone has or can get the
Cybus person's full docs or any other person that communicates
with him in Discord, including Wicked Supreme, please email me.
Thank you." >> Okay. So what did we know that what you're
using to justify doxing this cyber guy? So like what did Wiki
Supreme
>> Part of an online mass harassment community. Can you
open the next um >> what did he what did he actually what
did he actually do is like what did he what did he personally
do to justify >> engage with supported and encouraged the
mass harassment of anybody in the vicinity of >> he encouraged
he encouraged like what emailing rows? >> Okay. I'm just
curious on these sets of um messages go down to like the third
or fourth one where you can see there's like four emails or whatever
you can see in a You can read that on later too if you want.
>> What would you consider something when somebody's had
to >> do you think that that might look a little bit like
[__] harassment?
>> Well, let me look. And this is all from the same person
is assistance for I'm wear the fair clothes. I've been trying
to get a hold of your sister. I'm trying to hold your daughter.
I've been trying to get a hold of your Yeah. Look, I I'm just
going to be real. Like if I was if someone was trying to get
a hold of me and for whatever reason they couldn't get a hold
of me and then they started emailing my family, I would be >> Also,
hold on. Wait. Keep in mind, keep in mind this isn't just someone
that you know. This is a >> stranger. They started like
emailing my work, emailing illing. >> So, like I said,
>> my family, if somebody were to post stuff like this,
if somebody were to post a Discord server, here's proof of me
a girl who at best was a victim of just one person, at worst
is potentially a a a trafficking victim um to multiple men, right?
So, this person, I decided to spam emails to her. She stopped
responding then to her whole family using multiple email addresses.
If she's in a Discord server and all those people are like laughing
along and encouraging it and they're kind of like, "Yeah, okay,
cool, cool, cool." or whatever. Don't you think that's kind of
like a community of like crazy >> girl was engaging in
a back and forth? >> Wiki Supreme was like was like laughing
along and encouraging this. >> My question was for Wick.
>> Uh uh to be clear, um I think anyone who starts emailing
people's families when they can't get a hold of them, if you
don't know the personally,
especially if you're just a stranger. >> Oh, wait. He had
already Wait, they'd already established a rapport at that point.
like they'd already been emailing back and forth at that point.
>> In that circumstance, usually vault is creepy and weird
and should stop >> And then and then for an entire Discord
to be kind of like supporting it because they think it's going
to be a big own on me. They think they're going to own me for
it. So they're all like cool with it and they're like encouraging
it and joking about it and and supporting it. Isn't that a little
bit weird? >> Yeah, it is weird. >> Cool. All right,
that's all I needed. Good luck. >> So you're so So we got
Okay, ran away. So clearly there's no evidence of Wicked Supreme
doing any of the things that he just said. No evidence of me
doing any of that. No evidence of uh esports doing any of that.
Right. And so he's just saying that if you're in this community,
you deserve to be doxed, right? So if that's the case, given
that he has a community of doxers that he's uh put together and
he's encouraged. >> We literally he ran away. We all said
that was weird, by the way. We all said that was [__]
up. You shouldn't do that. We all had a discussion about it.
In fact, Destiny posted a bunch of the discussion we had. >> And
and we have evidence of these people, not only [__]
with people in real life. We have evidence that I'm about to
send you, Wick, of one of these guys uh uh offering to bully
the IRL, quote unquote. Okay, send me that evidence and we'll
show it on screen. >> Yeah. And with Destiny in the chat,
right, and he responds with like a based emoji, right? So, given
this is a community he's uh put together, like is is he just
saying it's totally justified to dox anybody in DG? I don't agree
with
>> Once we get it, I'll share it on screen. But to be clear,
doxing is bad. And I don't think that self-defensive doxing is
really a thing. So, just >> Yeah. And again, there's no
evidence that any of these people do anybody. He just keeps claiming
this with no evidence ever. As we saw with the um Riyle thing
where the evidence was of somebody said he docked somebody and
somebody else said that uh he wasn't he said he didn't do it
or whatever. The [__] wasn't sure he did it. >> Sure.
Just uh give me give me the screenshot though. >> Yeah.
One second. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah. I just messaged
Wicked and said I'd go on real quick. >> So I'm sending
to you right now, mister. >> Give me one second. >> I
actually don't know if he's going to invite me. I just said I
would come on >> like one Give me one second. >> One
second. I'm just going to read the highlighted part. Highlighted
part says Destin, this is from a gas 94 says, "Destiny, just
say the word and I can bully them IRL. Destiny feels okay, man."
And Destiny says later on based God. There you go. >> Yeah.
So, and this I think this was after he posted the Cyberdoc, the
first Cyberdoc, and then uh he previously posted Jox
uh and I think this was before he posted
um the esports Batman docs, right? All right. So, I think he
knows he has a community of people who are willing to these people
IRL. He's posting the doc's information in there uh to see if
they want to help quote unquote.
It seems pretty straightforward like what the intention is. Like
I don't know how else to explain that. Seems pretty [__]
straightforward. >> Fair enough.
>> Um so the cyber thing I don't know um
why all that happened played out the way it did. Uh Jay Silk
does. He knows way more about that than I do. He's offered to
come on and explain it. Uh, okay. If he wants to, um, send him
the invite and he can jump backstage and I'll pull him >> Go
one second. >> Where the [__] is the invite?
>> Sorry, I need two minutes here. One second. I I'm on
a phone call. I need two minutes. Like two minutes. >> And
to be clear to people in chat, like the the way that they uh
that Kiwi Farms found Rose is Destiny sent a a photo with her
face wearing a DG shirt in the university that she went to.
So the reason they doxed this girl and had the ability to harass
her at Kiwi Farms I mean was because he helped him do it. So
this pro clutching over harassment or whatever the is ridiculous.
Jay sucks he needs 2 minutes.
>> Uh okay. Well in that case let me use the restroom real
quick. I'll be right back. Okay. Uh entertain my stream. I will
be back.
>> Yeah. Here's another one I'm going to send you. Well
you can show when you get back. of the Zena girl who I think
anybody who knows the Zena girl um knows that she's pretty stable.
Um
she talks
uh she's asking Destin if she can like go see him whatever the
[__] And he says to her, "Yeah, only if you promise
to fight off Lauren if she shows up."
Um then here's another one. And she responds to him, "I don't
mind jail. Remember I I always say I'll get I'll go back and
proate twice this year." Yeah, I don't mind jail. Remember I
I always say I'll go back and prove it twice this year. So I
think he's demonstrated he has a community of people who are
kind of unhinged willing to people IRL forum. They've done it
already. And in this community he continues to post docin and
then post uh their information within this community asking people
for help quote unquote. So again pretty straightforward. And
he apparently thinks that if you're even in any of these servers
he is totally justified to dox you. So, and he started encouraging
people to dox me by the way. Um, when I had no I don't think
I was even in any of these servers of the time. I wasn't in uh
actually no I think it was in J server but I never spoken to
J-Hawk. Um I never spoken to the last time I spoke to Queen before
that was like a year or two before was a massive argument over
this Elder Drazzi guy. I was not friend with these people. Didn't
know them. But he accused me of being some with them and with
>> I'm here but I need 10 minutes in the server to do anything
>> to like take him down and pressure people uh not >> also
I like don't have like really good answers for the Sy like the
Cyber thing is what it is. I disagree with like talking to anyone
in her family. I disagree with sending those emails there. Right.
I personally disagree with that. But it's just I'm basically
gonna say it's not like people overly want
like like people don't support it. Like I don't support it. I've
made it clear >> that if you do like this you will be banned.
This was essentially that I was gone for like a couple weeks.
I bar I was barely able to stream. Right. And I didn't have time
to go through and figure out exactly what happened there. Have
you banned him? I have not banned him yet. Then ban him.
Oh, maybe get evidence that you said you didn't support it.
Oh. Oh, sure. I mean, I could just go and I Destiny knows this.
Destiny pulled it up on stream where we're like, "Oh, it's super
weird." What I would say is to me, it's like not weird until
he messages those other people and I'm like, "Oh, that's bad."
But realistically, he had a back and forth before that that was
totally fine. I think it's weird. I think if people do that in
the future, I'll ban them, right? Like, you can't reach out to
people through the audience. But he happened to get like he got
docked basically before I went over anything. I'm like, "Oh,
I think that's like punishment enough at this point."
Oh, he gave me a roll. Okay, hold on. Can I join? Let's see here.
Can I join? Can I join? I can't join. Do I have to join something
else? Betting room. Oh, here we go. All right. >> yeah,
but that's still not a That's >> Yeah, I don't think it's
okay. To be fair, I don't think it's okay. And I think they bullied
him over it and I wasn't okay with that and that's that's again
that's the reason we have this massive argument. Um I'm not go
ahead.
>> Yeah. Okay. >> I was just gonna say with regards
to the cyber thing like we all disavow that. I made it very clear
that if you reach out to people in this way in the future you're
perma banned. I by the time I got to go and look through all
of the stuff that was going on. So what I was aware of I was
aware of maybe a couple months ago that he was emailing and helping
her get her profiles taken down. Just to be clear, this is a
person emailing over and over again, right?
>> Well, so they had a normal back and forth, right? Like
Rose was messaging him back and saying, "Thank you for helping
me get this taken down." Right? He was helping her scrub. I think
it's super weird to do that to be honest.
But I wasn't like going to go and say, "Oh, well, stop taking
her profiles down for her. Stop helping her with this." So that's
what I was aware of. And then when I became aware later that
he'd messaged people in his family, I'm like, "Oh, that's up."
But by the time I became aware of it and like actually went through
what happened, he'd been doxed and I was like, "Oh, well, I don't
know. I feel like that's punishment enough and in the future
any kind of behavior like this is a perma." Like I totally disavow
it. I just kind of felt like, "Hey, you already got fully doxed
by Destiny." Seems like that was a
>> I don't know. I And also essentially everybody disavowed
this. Everybody's like, "This is super weird, like harmful behavior.
Don't do this." Like people might have meme'd in the channel
about I think things that
I I don't even know. I I don't think anybody supported it though.
Nobody was outright like no this is totally good.
>> And also it was like months after the fact. So I don't
even know how people could have encouraged it. >> Right.
How would you respond to the accusation that uh has been levied
against your community that you um you're a hotbed for people
to harass, stalk, dox, etc. What would be your response to that?
>> I think that's totally insane
and these allegations were made before the cyber thing happened.
It was the pretext for doxing all these people. And I don't understand
why they pretend they can reverse engineer and say, "Oh, well,
it was all justified because of this when they didn't even know
it was happening." So, they said this, they started doxing people,
but they up the timeline, right? They pretend finding out about
the cyber thing, which is bad. But again, I think the most critical
question is, did he lie or try to manipulate anybody? I don't
think so.
Like looking at the content of the messages, it seems like he
gave factual information. >> Yeah, that was my understanding
stuff taken down.
I would love to see any evidence they have that I'm connected
to harassment or doxing
>> To be clear, you didn't you didn't ban him because you
feel that he already suffered enough because he got doxed. That's
the justification for not banning >> and he's aware that
this behavior is totally unacceptable,
right? So, I am trying to be empathetic there. A lot of people
say just ban him and like you could be done with him and then
you just disavow and and throw him away and it's fine. By the
way, I'm not talking to Destiny, so just so you know.
>> that's that's how I look at it to talk about people.
Yeah, that's totally fine. I don't mind. Yeah, that's obviously
fine. Um,
so again, just me being empathetic.
Feel bad about it. Anyway, so I would want >> Wait, did
you say from before this? Like when he was doxing, right, originally?
Sorry, say that again, Dubie. >> So, did you say that you
found out about the SBA cyber thing months after it happened?
Yeah.
Okay.
>> Now, Destiny says he has one question for you. Can he
ask that question? >> You can ask it over text.
>> You won't you won't even let him in for just one question.
>> Okay, fair enough.
Uh, anything else? >> Uh, I just, like I said, the timeline
is what's broken here. So, I want evidence that I want basically
the Keell's manifesto standard, what he applied to his own community,
applied to my community. Show me evidence that anybody in my
community like participated in harassment in some way, in doxing
in some way, right? Harassment, I guess, is a loose line, but
doxing for sure because that was his original allegation. And
then show me evidence that it was sent to me, somebody informed
me or my community, and we protected that person and said that's
what we do here. Right >> now, I don't I'm unaware of any
evidence of us doxing somebody, somebody around Destiny. I'm
unaware of anything like that. But I'm saying that even if that
were to exist, you were to say, "Oh, well, actually, you had
a hidden Kiwi farm in your server the whole time." I didn't I
don't know about it. I would love to ban those people if anyone
could point them out.
>> And Jason, actually, while you're here, >> uh,
quickly though, because I do want, uh, Destiny be able to respond.
He only got like >> Yeah. Well, can you play this for a
second? Cuz, uh, Destiny explicitly said that he would suck and
if he could, and I think this was, was this before or after he
talks to you, to be clear. before definitely, but I can't remember
before or after
>> this before or after is attempted. >> Yeah. So,
it's it's I just sent you the video with the time stamp quick.
So, if you just play it, it'll play the right >> Sorry.
When it got published, it was definitely said before that. >> If
you want to just give me Destiny's question over text, I'm fine
to answer >> Oh, hold on. Give me a second. >> I'm
not preventing Destiny from talking. You can talk. You can come
on right after me. Just not directly talking to >> Yeah,
that's fine. Uh like hold on.
Uh he says, "No, never mind. I'm good. if he's too scared. So,
>> okay, let me >> I'm literally involved in stuff
in a way where directly speaking to him would be a bad idea,
>> Okay, give me a second. I'm trying to get through the
thing. Um, I don't have an ad blocker. That's a L for me. So,
I'm getting through this ad before I bring it up. >> And
we watch the time stamp he wants me to watch. So, one second.
Mhm. >> Yeah. So again, I believe that DGG applies like
standards to people for their behavior that they never apply
to themselves. There's no mirrored standard there, right? They
try to act like I'm at fault for some kind of doxing with no
proof. And then when Destiny outright doxes people, they're not
a doxing community. I mean, they clearly are a doxing. I think
you could agree on that, Wick, right? That it's a doxing community
at this point. >> I think Destiny doxes. But what what
doxes has his community done? Well, I think they reposted that
wick >> like a ton of you on that that Destiny has done,
but I don't know if I've seen >> No, if you scroll up,
um I think you will find uh Yeah, I have food shop stocks right
here um coming up. And this is not Destiny. This is some Kaiser
guy. Um and then it's uh Andreas,
if you let me tell you exactly who it is. And actually, this
is Destiny talking to some Andreas guy. So, apparently it's been
news for a long [__] time. Let me tell you exactly
who it is. you dumb dumb folks can go dox them and DM them. Okay.
Um from Nameless Dan already pulling up the docs info classic.
Um from uh Nunia's Destiny disease for sports Batman four years
working at a highend law for firm. Uh then some other guy uh
he claimed to be an M and lawyer. So these people are helping
him like actively helping him dox people right. So uh this other
person says metal metaloid sword gives you the man's full docks
and and you're asking who he is to destiny. like very obvious
this community helps and docs people, right? So like >> I
don't know why >> accurate then. Yes, that would be the
>> Yeah, it's Well, it's in the DMs that I
>> I got I can only show one thing at a time, though. >> That's
okay. Yeah, I got it. >> Um, do you want me to watch this
now?
>> Yes, please. >> Okay. Okay. I assume that was
a relevant
>> Yeah. So this and this is like I said I think before
>> oh there is one more point in there where he says he
wants >> Jason he wants queen he wants laugh he wants Mr.
broke. I don't know. There's two different points where he talks
about wanting people.
>> I think he says, "I wish someone would kill him." >> And
I can get that subsc
who's who's also helping him dox people.
>> it's pretty straightforward.
>> Anything else that you want to say, JT Stalk, while
you're here? >> Oh, I heard that you said that Queen doxed
Elder Drazzi. That happened. >> Yeah, absolutely. Or at
least he was involved in that. Can we just run that down real
quick? Can we just like clear that up? >> Yeah. So, it
wasn't it wasn't sound like it sound like the uh Yeah, I can
explain it. So, because I said I had a massive argument with
him about this, right? So, um it wasn't as explicit as he went
to track down this information. Elder Drazzi had a Twitch channel.
His uh PayPal was linked to that channel and the PayPal had his
full name and city, right? So, of course, people saw this eventually
at some point and they decided to [__] with him,
pull it up, and they found pictures of his wife over the umqman
was uh initially mocking him, I think, but then started deleting
it and other people were deleting it. But then they kept making
jokes about his name, like uh like using his last name and little
like uh puns or whatever the I didn't think that was okay. [laughter]
So, I said, "Hey, you shouldn't be doing this. You shouldn't
be allowing this." And I had a massive argument with him and
tried um on stream about this. So, it wasn't like they wanted
to go track this [__] down. It was literally linked
to his profile
afterwards it right. They did spread it. >> Yeah. And then
afterwards they helped
>> Yeah. I agree. That's why I had a massive argument with
him about it. Then afterwards uh they did help him like remove
it and then showed him how to like remove the stuff that was
publicly >> accepted damage done at that point man. >> Yeah.
I agree which again that's why I had a huge argument with him
about it. So but what I'm curious about is people in chat saying
how like terrible that is. That's I agree with you. That's pretty
bad. which is why I argued with him about this because I'm consistent.
Um, but
Destiny has doxed multiple people with no justification.
>> He claims that they're doxers. No evidence of this.
He he claims that oh well bad and empanada do somebody so therefore
they say it's okay to dox you makes no sense. So like all of
you like ders in chat talking about oh that's terrible of queen.
How dare you? Like just apply the standard to yourself and your
community. >> Yeah. And I would just say again, I want
to reh highlight the timeline. So Destiny says he's like honest
about his behavior, that he's okay with doxing people. We all
know that. But what he's not honest about is his justification.
What he was mad about was that Queen and I were covering the
court case and that we talk [__] about him. That's
why he was doxing people. He just doxes people over like petty
personal beef. That's his like modus operandi. He doesn't dox
people defensively. He doesn't dox people who dox other people.
He just doxes anyone who them for a prolonged period of time.
That's the message he wants to get out. It's why he basically
said that Pisco server was fair game earlier today, right? >> Yeah.
He said it's like a terrorist server or some >> Yeah. So,
it it's I mean it's it's obvious what his like operating procedure
is. Guy's kind of losing it. Anyway, I'm guessing you want to
get him back on here to talk. So, >> well, I don't think
he I think he's he's good. So, probably not. He's probably not.
I don't know if he will. But either way, uh I do thank you for
coming on and giving your side of the story. Cool.
Yeah. Cool. Thanks. Bye. >> Yeah. Wait,
>> I'm not following this. >> Yeah, cool. Thanks.
>> Yeah. Would you mind playing the es because esports
Batman is one of the people that I mentioned. He actually did
confront Destiny. Um, finally to get some kind of justification
for the doxing. Um, would you mind if I send that to you? >> Send
it. >> And you could Would you play? >> Is it long?
>> I think it's like a minute or two. >> Okay, we
can watch a minute or two. >> Okay, one second. Let me
grab it. Yeah. So, this guy um I don't know if you know who Esports
Batman is, but he was like a former Orbiter dude. >> Um
and my understanding of what he's been doing is he's been helping
um JTO go through like the public court filings. Um same ones
that Destiny reads on stream, I think. Um and Destiny feels like
the way that he's interpreting these is incorrect. >> Thank
you. You think I did a good job >> and this is what justifies
doxing him.
>> one second. And here it is. Oh, the I meant to say also
I have no interest in talking to Destiny directly because he
just spurs like a child instead of actually engaging with an
argument somebody makes >> and there is no actual there's
no reasonable purpose to engage with him directly. You can just
say what you want to say, listen to his response after and then
respond, >> right? He is just going to scream over you
while you talk. It's actually totally pointless to have any conversation
with him directly.
>> And then there's another one about Pisco, I think. >> Yeah.
Well, let's get through one at a
No, I again I'm just explaining it to you on the ideas. Destiny
loses, right? He loses completely. He can't compete in the ideas
and so he has to come and spur and try to like derail the whole
time. That's why I don't know if Wick will >> three minutes
and we can do three minutes, right gang? Okay, you guys have
that attention span? I hope you do. Uh you ready? Watch it. >> I'm
not again I'm literally I already said the first reason the primary
reason is that I'm involved in a way that direct confrontation
is stupid. Like I don't want to have any direct conversation
with this guy at all. Respond to statements from him. He can
respond to statements from me. Totally fine with that. Okay.
But beyond that, also for most people, there's no reason to actually
have a conversation with this person. He's obviously bad faith
at all times.
>> So
that's why. >> And if I was just doing this for cloud online,
I'd love to try that out. Toxopplasmosis or toxo plas plasmopus.
Okay. It's all right. >> I know you. >> Oh, go ahead.
Let's watch this. >> So, why? >> That's it. Question.
>> No. No answer. You're You're just gonna sit here.
>> Are you esports Batman? >> Yes. He knows. >> Wait,
is it? >> Oh my god. >> Is it Batman?
>> Oh, you never knew this. Okay, so come on. I got I got
limited time here. Don't waste it. Why? >> Why? What? >> Why
did you do me? >> What? Me? What?
Uh, yes. Yeah.
>> Would I ever do that? >> It's the first time I'm
hearing about >> Oh, okay. Yeah, of course. So, come on.
Be an adult. Own up to it. Why?
>> I don't know. I have to check my logs.
>> Oh, you don't even know. Okay. >> Wait, do you
have those logs? >> Yes, I do. >> I'm asking you.
I don't know. >> I'm asking you right now. Why? >> Uh,
yes. >> There's a lot of >> How do you feel about
those emails that Sab was shooting around? I don't think that
I think they were in good faith, but I think they were a little
bit over the line. But I had nothing to do with them. So
why I'm not concerned about SA? I'm concerned about me. What
did I do
>> You know, 8X is our 50 highqual, right?
>> Okay. That's what I thought. Okay. So when I have my
call later on this afternoon with a couple of people, you just
have no reason. I want I want to be on the record about this
so that I can say I've spoken with you directly and asked you
why. >> Wait, are you that mad? the people asking you,
"Bro, if you care so much, why don't you do something?" >> What
loser is Are you Are you that mad that you got doxed and they
put it on a swatting website? Are you that mad? >> Well,
anything that happens going forward, I want to let you know that
it's all thanks to you, buddy. Everything that happens going
forward. >> Yeah, you lit a fire underneath my butt. So,
I want to thank you very much by saying, "Put up or shut up."
So, I would like to take this opportunity to recognize your encouragement
and
encouraging motivation of of of you. >> No, friendly. Hey.
>> there's a person in here too. >> Do you have an
answer or are you just going to play quick? >> Wait, why
did you name yourself sports Batman? Do you play video games?
>> Uh, my answer is I consider every single person that's
actually participating in that um discord to be basically the
equivalent of a terrorist. Um, I think that you by giving your
absolute legal advice, most of which has been totally incorrect
and the other parts have illustrated you can barely read. Um,
I think make you cop. Why would his legal advice his bad legal
I I doxed you over bad legal advice. >> Basically everything
that's going on in the Discord server. So suck my dick. >> Thank
you. That's all I need to hear. >> Have fun. Be careful.
>> Okay. Uh the next one I think about Pisco
and but also Pisco too. Pisco has >> um very long. Pisco
has never anybody, never been encouraged, never got anything
anything like this. They never asked anybody. His crime is disagreeing
with Destiny about a couple issues. >> questions. Yeah.
Go ahead. Um wait, so you see like it's like justified of like
doxing the guy, the um useful banning
>> Yeah, that whole should be [__] wiped off
the internet everywhere banned from Discord and everybody in
there should be probably locked in for like 12 months. Guess
they basically been long like long-term stalking and harassing
me and people around me for yeah about a year now. It's been
I think it's pretty relentless, pretty insane. And when it's
got to the point where that save guy is literally bragging about
emailing like a victim in my court case and is and everybody
in that server is like clapping along and laughing at it is yeah
I think it's I'm good on that >> Sorry is catching up.
So >> docs like any other like these years >> they
don't need to. every doc is posted on KB farms that they actively
collaborate with. Why would they dox anybody in justical server?
That'd be
>> Do you think um you kind of overreacted of like by like
doxing a couple of people inside the J community a little
>> No, they I don't think they have like I'm I'm not trying
to like downplay, but like I don't think they cause you like
physical harm, right? I don't think from a tri. >> Okay.
I don't think I caused them physical harm. Did I? >> Not
that I'm aware of. No. >> No. Well, then we're good. >> Like
other examples of like doxing like
>> Spider's not the smartest >> at this point. Actually,
I just I don't care what happens to any of these communities
like Pisco included. I think that all you guys are weird and
need to be wiped from the internet. I think it's all like gotten
way out. >> By the way, by the way, Dan got doxed by like
Kiwi Farms when Dan and I were super close friends and Dan would
come on my stream was because Dan was talking about doxing other
people. >> I'm like at this point I don't give a [__]
about any of it. Shrimp ass. >> Big spider. Are you guys
gotten way too comfortable talking and being weird just talking
harassing people?
>> Kind of weird. >> I probably J more.
>> I thought a few people left the server once people started
getting dark. That's what I saw. >> Wow. It's almost like
he's just deliberately trying to like community
on this. I am getting tired. Um, is there
is there anyone else who wants to come in and challenge Doobie?
Who's the most who wants it the most, gang? Okay, we got one
more. This will be the last one, then we'll close out for tonight.
Um, then I'll read those super chats actually and then we'll
close out for tonight. But Zip Zip, hi.
>> Oh, hey. What's up? >> Hey, what do you got?
>> Uh, I'm a couple. >> Let's see. What do you think
Zip Zip's position is? >> I'm sure like these people are
like watching. So, just so there's like no confusion or anything
or they can't pretend like, oh, I wasn't aware or whatever. Uh,
just to be clear or last night, uh, person morale who's in Jto
server threatened to dox me. Um,
excuse me being a um, just to be clear, that's what happened.
Uh they were very explicit that they wanted to get my address
and come to my house. This is very clear. This is a person in
Jto server. Notable member I know you I'm trying to think of
the exact quote from Ralph. I think Ralph said something along
the lines of
you a child and I'm going to come to your house in real life
to show you the video of you a child.
Uh I do not believe Zip Zip has ever a child. I'm pretty sure.
Bam.
Uh you can pretend whatever the [__] you want what
you will about this person. Um
>> that is what happened in the server. That is what's
allowed. This person has not been banned. >> Uh they probably
won't be. Although they might be now because I'm calling it out
so directly, but that's what's happening. So >> I'd like
to respond when he's done talking if that's okay. >> Sure.
Are you done talking?
>> Yeah. Yeah, you can go ahead. >> Go ahead. >> So
I've Yeah, I've interacted with Ma. I don't know this person.
We're not like friends or anything, but uh if they did threaten
to dox you, I don't support that. I think it's bad. I think it's
wrong. Um, but to be clear, not only have you justified dxing
doxing people, but you were the guy that was laughing in the
background. No, I'm not done. You were the guy that was laughing
in the background when esports Batman was in there. Um, >> yeah,
like talking to him about the docks, right? >> Okay. So,
you also you're part of a doxing community and now you're on
here uh pretending to play the victim um because somebody apparently
threatened >> It's possible that two instances of doxing,
one could be justified, the other cannot be justified, right?
That's >> What justifies what justifies esports? >> What
justifies mine?
I don't know. I I don't support it. You You think one of them
is justified. So like which one is >> I am curious. What
does justify esports on your mind? Zip. >> I'm agnostic.
I don't really care. >> Okay. So you you don't have a >> He
doesn't have a position, guys.
Oh my god. You're You're telling me this for the first time.
Zip Zip doesn't have a position. Oh my god.
You're I've never seen this before. [laughter] >> You said
Hold on. I think you said one's justified, right? >> Well,
no. He said it's possible. Therefore, you can hold a different
standard for one versus the other. I'm not interested in esports
getting dogs. I'm more interested in mine. >> Yeah, I don't
support you docs to be clear. Good for you. >> I hope everyone
else in that server agrees cuz you guys really care about doxing.
Um so I hope that because this is going to happen and I'm sure
uh if that ban doesn't happen uh you yourself are going to personally
reach out to JTO to try to get that person banned, right? >> No,
that's not my business. It's his server. If he wants to ban him,
it's his it's his business. >> Well, just just in if in
case he's not aware, right? like you you >> I think he's
aware
again I would support I would support people in the server like
talking about it since well I'm not you can look at the server
I'm not very active in the server right hop I pop >> listen
if Zip Zip if Zip Zip felt threatened okay if Zip Zip felt like
this was what was going to happen then you know what we'll we'll
>> but wait one second one second so I did a thing so yeah
>> we don't even we don't even participate usually we don't
even do offser uh conduct okay we don't ban for that kind of stuff
ban them But it's not my server. So, you know, uh if he doesn't
do it, it's his his progressive. >> I'm aware it's not
your server.
>> Do you have anything else for >> um So, hold on.
So, J just messaged me say that they already banned him and it
was a joke. >> That's great. I'm happy to hear it.
>> Cool. So, do you support Destiny? Um actually Destiny
is helping banned, but Destiny banning uh other people in this
community who part participated in >> Uh no. So, I was
going to bring up that uh earlier you pretend to like not know
why you were banned from Pisco server. Uh it was because you
were uh there were two reasons. one uh the weird
was making people uncomfortable in the server. The other thing
was accusing me of going to a public court hearing to stalk Pixie
and onto her car. [laughter] Uh I think it's just a weird thing
to say. Um the service
two things joking or not they said so it wasn't they didn't think
it was serious. They said even if it's a joke it's still >> Okay.
Okay. both of you stop. Both of you stop because I want I want
Zip Zip to answer your question. I want you to answer Zip Zip's
question. >> Yeah totally fine. So again, um, ask your
question directly to Zip Zip and then Zip Zip address it and
then Zip Zip can make his allegation and you can directly address
it. Go ahead. Go ahead, Dubie. Ask ask your question. >> Oh,
okay. So you do support, um, actually, do you support um, >> you
told different? No. >> Okay. You don't have no opinion
at all as to whether or not these people been people in Destiny's
community should be
>> Okay. Do you want to respond to the allegation that
you were pretending not to know about that? Cuz I don't know
if you remember a few months ago. >> I don't talk about
harassment on this exact harassment. You >> almost identical
situation as this one, right? So just to be just to be clear
as I remember just to be clear just to be clear as I remember
it Doobie you did accuse Zip Zip of going to the courthouse to
jizz >> accused is a strong word who so I'll >> okayain
[laughter]
I don't want I was active right um pretty often um one day look
at the chat people were talking about the zip guy right who said
um and they're saying oh yeah he went to the court hearing or
whatever um to like and like I think they were joking about him
like taking pixie shoes shoes or some right so I asked so I asked
him if went the court hearing. He was being really cy about it.
Wasn't just like answering the [__] question. I think
that be really weird. I wasn't like trying to attack him. Ask
him a straightforward question. Hey, did you actually go to court
case? >> Yeah. I don't I don't think that's I think it's
a straightforward question. You did go I don't know why you wouldn't
just say yes. So as a throw joke I said you went there to like
drop off on a car or something and you >> doubled
down, right? >> Hold on. Hold on. The reason I cuz you
took Yeah, cuz you took that and it was like I keep your dog
or something. You like brought it up constantly. No, I just think
it's a weird thing to say
We good? Which I think is true. Got really [__] defensive.
>> Feels very violated in some way, which is why the court
case exists. I don't know why you talk about that personal object.
It's just got really defensive when I said that. It's a joke,
right? We had this conversation. I thought it was pretty obvious.
>> We had it with >> W. We did. We did. But Zip,
I got I got a question for you, Zip. >> Just Just real
quick, Zip Zip, I have a question for you. Uh Jtock wants to
ask you a question. Is that okay? >> Uh wait, say again.
>> J wants to ask you a question. Is that >> Uh sure.
Sure. He asked me lots of questions last night in Pisco server.
>> okay. Well, if JSTock wants to jump backstage, I'll
pull him on and he can ask you that question directly. So, JTalk
um that's answer your question. >> Well, wait. Do you have
the question?
>> no, he's going to jump on and ask you. >> Oh,
he's going to jump in and ask. Okay. >> I just point out
while he's coming in how how funny is that he has no opinion?
>> Talk to Destiny. But that's okay. I'll just talk to
him. >> Oh, well, too late, man. You just said okay, so
I actually Yeah, it's good. I'm just realizing >> I literally
just actually laid out for Wick if he doesn't want to. I was
like, if he doesn't want to talk to me, you could just ask him
the question yourself. I wasn't going to force you to talk to
me again. I know. >> You're going to force me.
>> Okay. I just wanted to ask, did you think So, Mau is
somebody who does like over-the-top humor. >> He's never
doxed somebody. He's never been accused of doing that. Okay.
So, he was doing a bit. I banned him anyway
concern for your safety. Do you do you feel it was a sincere
doxing threat? Did you feel it was a sincere doxing threat? >> I
do. Yes. >> Do you remember what he said to you >> Uh
many things. Yeah.
>> Okay. Cuz what I can
for my myification
be more specific. >> Do Yeah. Do you want to >> I
don't think I will be more specific about what would lead me
to believe that there's a genuine threat of a dox at least on
the stream. >> So absolutely no basis whatsoever. >> Wait,
that's perfectly reasonable reasonable thing for me to not want
to talk about. Right. >> No, just just so I'm clear. >> Oh,
do you not want it brought up at all? Will >> not bring
it up at all. >> Yeah. Just just >> I don't care
if you bring it up. I'm just not both of you. Please, >> just
to be clear, just so I know, you don't want to talk about it
because something he said
clued you into the fact that he had actual information about
you that he might share. And >> no, I'm not saying any
of that. Just the particulars of
I'm not I'm saying I don't want to discuss the specific clue
>> as to that, but I do think it was a genuine threat.
>> So you you thought it was a genuine threat. Okay. So
from what I understand
without any indication that this was true at all started saying
you were a >> correct right >> that that was one
part of it. Yeah. >> Is that what cleared you that he might
have actually do you?
>> Uh no.
So he kept calling you a and you said what evidence do you have
of this? And I believe he said I will come to your house personally
and show you the video of you the child. Which is like an over
the top obvious joke. >> That was one of the things that
was said. But I still banned him because >> before that
I said, "Well, if you have evidence, if you purport to have a
video," uh, and they they were very specific that they had a
video. Well, I asked them to show evidence. They said they didn't
want to show me porn. >> And Dick was like, "Don't send
me any."
>> and he was going to show up to your house specifically
to show you the
>> I don't know.
So you your read on that was that he had a video of some other
and he was sincerely saying that he wanted to go
>> okay or more likely I think that that was completely
>> Wait, didn't he didn't he say that the reason he don't
want to talk about is because he had like some some something
he said had given like some implication that he actually >> No,
that was that was my
my wife. So maybe I miss Yeah. >> Yeah. So Ralph knows
that he in my server the rule is Ralph, you've had enough warnings
about getting close to the line with your shock jock humor. You
don't get more warnings in my server. So when he was doing it
in someone else's server, it's whatever. Like I wasn't necessarily
going to act on it. If you feel like it was a sincere threat,
he's been warned about this conduct in my server, right? I know
it's a joke. I know he's never doxed anybody. I know he's not
like at a risk of doxing
>> Yeah. Well, sorry. I just know that he's never doxed
anybody. You have proof
>> No.
Wait. Okay. Why were you saying
quite a lot? Well, sorry. Why were you
that you would not believe it's possible that I would think it's
genuine threat? >> Are you >> I don't think I don't
believe you. But I also banned him just because I'm like, "Okay,
well, you know, >> you're you're complaining about it.
So, I'll ban him. I don't want to." >> It's like a similar
thing, right? Cuz like I made an obvious joke you didn't think
it was. >> If you didn't ban him, it would look really
bad for you, right? So, >> this guy's reputational entirely.
>> Also, take it super seriously. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. So that's why you did it like just for your reputation,
not because you actually believe that it was a genuine threat
at all. >> Yeah. Like I believe he was joking. I know he
was joking, but I said I would ban people who make jokes and
so I did.
>> You weren't there though, so you have no clue actually
>> as we as we say?
>> So you you believe he was going to show up with the
uh
>> with the evidence of you doing this? >> This is
this is I think the car door
>> or at least docks me. That's was being suggested. They
said that they were going to make a Google doc and uh with my
information and share that. That's what they're saying they were
going to do. That Yeah, that's what they said they were going
to do. Yeah.
>> Okay. All right. Okay.
>> If they did that
>> that'd be terrible. >> Well, that would be insane.
But I mean, I'm banning him for the threat because Zip Zip feels
threatened. I just wanted to ask Zip Zip if he really felt threatened
cuz I don't believe he did. But if he's going to claim he did,
then I'm fine with leaving him perma banned. You don't you don't
think it's plausible I did? >> Or plausible perhaps? >> No,
I don't think it's >> I think I think it's as you thinking
I was really accusing you of coming on corridor. Yeah, I think
these two >> might not be for you. Maybe it's because you've
already been doxed. You just don't care about this sort of thing.
But yeah, I generally
threaten to dox you, right? >> Just to be clear, I do care
because like I don't want that to happen. And I don't want people
to make joking doxing threats because I don't believe as many
people are as over the top or as like not serious about his morale
is. So I'm fine with holding up that ban to make you feel safe.
>> Okay. Okay. Is there anything else you have? Zip Zip
or Jay talk one of the >> I want to be I want to be the
coming on the car door thing. So the when he got really defensive
I started to actually feel like he might have come came on the
door, right? Um so now I do think to be clear that he did come
on the door at least twice. Um, maybe on every door. Maybe the
door handle specifically. I'm convinced just because of the extremely
defensive behavior over that like stupid joke that I made. >> Yeah.
Honestly, with given that he brought up the car door handle like
tribute like tribute on the cart door handle. Given that he brought
that up, I actually do believe he might have taken moral seriously.
So,
this actually is consistent. >> Wait, that brought apologize
for accusing you of lying. >> Wait, just like why did I
bring that up? >> I think it might be I think it might
be >> No, no, no. Shut the [__] up. Is your
Why did you bring up the coming on the door handle thing? >> I
brought it up in every conversation you've participated in that
remotely approaches dubbie as a topic >> for the past couple
weeks. >> Wait, why would that be the case? >> You
bring it up. Wait, did you bring it up yesterday with >> Ashley
Wick? I think the last time we spoke on
I think the last time I spoke to Zip Zip on here, he brought
with the car door thing. >> Good luck. That or maybe not.
>> I think the last time I spoke to Zip Zip on here, he
brought with the car door >> Well, that Yes, that was [laughter]
Hold on just real quick. Just real quick. Hey, please just just
real quick. He did reference that. Um uh he just he did reference
that before and he said that's why we probably shouldn't talk
about it again because we already litigated again. That's what
Zip Zip said. So, >> well, hold on. But he came in here
and he brought it up. He claimed there was a reason
to be clear.
>> Ridiculous. You know, it's ridiculous. >> I just
Why did I bring it up? >> The The reason it's so funny
is cuz it's like so outlandishly. It's so cartoonishly goofy,
right? The reason we have an issue with Destiny isn't because
he's like making jokes, right? It's not because he's making jokes.
If he WAS JUST MAKING JOKES, NOBODY'D HAVE A PROBLEM, DOG. The
issue is that he's actually doing the things
because you're now claiming. >> No, he is like actually
I wasn't joking when I said maybe he took it seriously when Ralph
said was being like super over the top. He picked a bad target.
This guy does seem to take things >> That is one of the
reasons I was banned. And I I think >> that is one of the
stated reasons why you're banned. Correct. Well, if that's true,
just real quick,
you think it's silly to think that um telling someone over and
over again that they're going to come on a car door. Uh [laughter]
just just to be clear, because the reasons that I was sent that
you were banned were in part. >> Sorry, really quick. Wick,
why couldn't you maintain a straight face saying it? >> Personal
harassment. >> Did that not count as personal >> No,
I think it was again silly joke that I made as a story line.
He clung to it. I think I I joked that it might be true, but
I think this was like maybe like a week or two before I was banned,
before the Destiny um uh stream or whatever with Pisco. So yeah,
I think I think they would ban me for that over a week later
is ridiculous. It's a silly throwaway joke. >> If I were
like chasing in the message where they said I was reason, they
said even jokingly. >> So the message
serious thing >> I think what actually happened and I think
you know this is this people didn't like
okay I think people didn't like me because I agree this agreed
with me and I agree with and so mods there and also because I'm
like a rabid anti-Israel guy and there many people in their support
and I usually argue with him about that. Um, and this Palms guy
came in. Other people like, "Oh, I he got banned because he was
like one of these mont." And so he banned him and then he gave
his colle to make Ben sick. I think he actually said this. I
think I have a great screen of this. So yeah, it's it's being
silly. >> Okay. I don't know what that has anything to
do with what I was talking about the state of reasons why you're
banning. Yeah. >> I never
I just told you why.
>> You don't think it's true. However, you just never bring
it up. You bring the one, but you don't have to bring that one.
Those >> were to be clear. This was the first time anybody's
ever told me that I was related to Ben ever. And I think again,
given that was a throwaway joke made like like a week or two
before. I think
this is not the first time this has been brought up to you. I'm
so sorry to tell >> Zip Zip has turned and there's not
like a reputational risk to the car door handle thing. Zip >> trying
to remember in our last conversation
that's literally why it was brought up. Bro, >> I I I [__]
I'm going to be honest with you guys. I can't remember the details
of that conversation enough to say whether or not um who's right
in this case cuz I it was like months ago and I don't remember.
>> Yeah, fair enough. >> No, that's that's the thing.
I think I don't know why he's so worked up about the Cardor thing.
Um given that it was again a third >> No, I'm not worked
up about it. I just think it's funny that you pretend that >> I
mean according to Jason, he brought it up in every conversation
that even remotely approaches me for weeks now.
>> um I don't know how many conversations I'm having that
remotely approach you. >> Um if I bring it up last night
with Pisco, it's cuz it's came up. >> I also just think
it's funny that so maybe it could have just be that >> I
agree it's funny. That's why I said it. had it come up last night
with >> it. So maybe I think it's funny as well and so
I like laughing at you. >> No, I think that's why I bring
it up. >> No, I don't think you think it's funny. I think
you think that I was Well, hold on. I don't think you actually
believe that I was making a serious accusation. I think you're
pretending you think I >> You think I actually think that
you're >> justify this this this claim that I'm like spreading
lies about you or
>> Do you think that's
No, no. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Uh Dub, I said this earlier. Maybe
you weren't paying attention or you weren't listening. So, I
said that I came in to bring that up >> just because you
were ignoring that as one of the stated reasons why you were
>> But that wasn't the stated reason why I was banned.
>> That was Do you Do you want evidence of this or? >> Yeah,
I'd love that. >> Hold on. Yeah, if if you have evidence,
DM it to me. >> I'll send it to Wick. Uh, scroll up a bit
in our thing.
>> okay. Uh, I see >> a screenshot. You can pull
that up. >> Yeah, give me a second. I >> I don't
But maybe it's maybe that's how simple it has to be. >> I'll
just read it out again. Uh, so Scuzzy says it's because he's
a socialist. I'm kidding. I don't actually know. And then Premier
Katchcha says, and and Premier Kcha is actually, she's in my
community. If she's watching this, uh, she could just jump backstage
and clarify. Um, he says, "Weird comments about skin color preferences
and gross accusations, mostly not serious, but still gross towards
Zip Zip. Also, hi Zip. How are you? How are you today?" So according
to Premier Katcha, that is one of the reasons you were banned,
dooby. >> When was that post made?
>> [__] lip color. What the >> Okay.
So to be clear, if you look at the chat right when I was banned,
um you will find people telling >> Do you think I'll deny
any of this?
>> No, I don't think you will.
>> Yeah. So you'll find people telling um this Palms guy
uh to ban me just because they don't like me, basically. Uh they're
accusing me of being like uh trying to turn Pisco against
being being responsible for Pisco's opinions on Destiny. Uh and
that's why I was actually banned. Right. So I know that later
they tried to come up with the reasons to justify it. Again,
initially I was told it was because I was like weird comments
about >> So just to be clear, you're accusing Premier Ki
of lying there. >> Yeah, I am. >> Okay. Okay.
>> Yeah. I think they this Palms guy banned me, paid 500
bucks, and they came up with reasons to justify later. Yeah.
>> Okay. Um, but you agree though that that was one of
the stated reasons was you're joking about. >> Well, hold
on. This this is the first time I've seen the screenshot and
this the first time I >> don't believe it is because we
had this conversation before. >> It is possible,
but this is
brought up. >> So, you said the screenshot itself wasn't
brought up. So, yeah.
That was a current I wasn't aware that was a current lie there
on. Yeah. >> Okay. Well, uh, this has been great, gang.
Uh, Zip Zip, is there anything else you want to say before I
let you >> Uh, I don't know. I think it's just really funny
that Jay Dakata coming here to defend Dubbie cuz uh he was saying
in his own server that uh should be making claims that he's not
sending
>> uh why he would die on Lauren Deluno. Uh Laguna had
been at Daryus's house literally like a couple weeks before u
hanging out with Daryus's roommate. Uh she was unaware of who
Daryus was. Just like there's there's a million different things.
It's obviously true that Destiny's narrative
truth. >> If you don't want to characterize that as harassment,
>> it's totally fine. I literally didn't mention Lauren
Dea. Didn't defend Doobie. I just gave my reasonings for >> I
mean, but you know, >> he was he was being honest about
the the ban thing though, right? Like he wasn't lying about that.
>> No, it wasn't. It was only about that >> But but
I think Okay, go ahead. >> Yeah. No. Um I'm just going
to let Zip Zip go. Um thank you.
>> Yeah.
All right,
Thank you for being here today. Um, and thank you for agreeing
to let Destiny come on and uh grill you a little bit and uh >> No
problem. >> Yeah. Is there anything you want to say before
I get through super chats and go through all that? >> I
would just encourage people to look for the evidence that JTON
um Wicked Supreme, esports Batman, any of these people, right?
anybody from Joff's community has done any of this doxing that
Destiny's accused him of before he started accusing them of doxing
anybody or even since so far as I'm aware I found none of it
right and um uh he's also accused me of being involved with it
looked like doxing kiwi farms there's no evidence of this it's
all just like this uh concocted
that he's put together to justify uh trying to silence people
who criticize him we all know this is what it is exactly why
he's making the same allegations toward Pisco associating Pisco
with these communities is the most ridiculous thing I've ever
heard in my life. Now, I can understand um assuming these things
about me again with no evidence, but I mean Wick, you've known
Pisco for years. I've known Pisco for years. He would never do
anything like that, right? He's never he would never be involved
with >> No, I don't think he's involved in community. No.
>> Yeah. So, so Destiny claiming that he's involved with
these communities and that he's like a a terrorist or whatever
the we need to be like purged off the >> Oh, by the way,
I didn't say that. That was my dog. So I said attempt every single
time >> this lie clear lie should be evidence every guy
should not be trusted everybody everything >> I literally
said that there's just no reason to talk to Destiny that he so
Destiny just spurs over people instead of actually addressing
it I'm totally fine having a decent like what do you call it
uh like a nonreal time like a turnbased back and forth right
that's why I said if he wanted to ask a question to me directly
he could just send Wick the text message
and then I could decide whether or not to answer it. Yeah, just
an asynchronous conversation. Fine with responding to each other,
but I have no reason. Right. >> Okay. We went over >> a
clip of what Mal said. Oh,
will you please unban him? No, I I don't know if I'm going to
unban him right now. Um, if I watch the clip and it's like clearly
absurdest humor. Mal's got multiple warnings here. Okay.
Sorry. Uh, yeah. M, it's like a prolonged bit. M just Yeah. No,
I understand. It's a bit I'm going to leave him banned for banned
until I hear the clip and then I'm going to leave him banned
for a little bit. Okay. But it's like it's an obvious bit. But
Zip Zip's complaining and I can't say, "Well, we don't dox cuz
if you report somebody who's made a doc threat, I'll I'll ban
first. I'll shoot first and ask questions later."
>> Dude, I'm sorry. I'm literally Dude, I'm I'm out of
it. Oh, my bad. I'm like typing Wix Discord. I had totally I
like basically walked away. You guys >> see same thing
for I literally just forgot I was streaming.
>> I literally just forgot I was streaming cuz I'm arguing
with people Wix Discord. That's my bad. Twist himself. Jesus
Christ. Pretend it's not dude. I totally forgot I was I was just
like I was in it. I was in it typing. Okay.
>> People have done
harassment campaign. >> You send me the clip. Thank you.
Okay. Let's get through these super chats. You with me? Let's
do it. >> $2 from Bella Bean. Haha, Doobie is a coward
that needs to get alive. Thank you for >> Oh, dude. I don't
I don't want to play recordings from that that Discord call because
I don't think Piscoll wanted it recorded and I feel like if he
doesn't want it recorded, playing the recordings from it on stream,
it's tanamount to having recorded it myself and I just don't want
to get
one. Doobie's politics are frog in nature and gay pilled
>> 5B reasonable from Rice Wit. Uh, is Doobie able to appreciate
Destiny's political debate content despite disliking him personally?
>> I'm sorry. Say that one more time. >> Is Dubbie
able to appreciate Destiny's political debate content despite
disliking him personally? >> Yeah. So, there have been
a couple um I don't know if there are panels or debates uh like
one-on-one debates. I think it was one-on-one debate that he's
engaged in that I saw because somebody else reacted to it and
I agreed with him, right? And I appreciated the debates. But
>> sorry, even if it's leaked though, I don't think I even
if it's leaked, I don't think I play it
on. Oh, it's on kick. Yeah, even if it's leaked, I don't know if
I play it. >> I only watch that because somebody else was
reacting to it. I I don't even feel comfortable giving the guy
view on YouTube. Like, that's how much I want to disassociate
from promoting him in any way or helping him in any way. >> Fair
enough. >> So, so yeah, like I don't again, >> it's
a $5 question. You only have to give a $5 answer, right? >> This
is a $5 answer. Okay. I don't think he's a I don't think he's
a monster. I just think he's a massive piece of [__]
and a malicious liar and I feel like people should triple check
everything he >> $2 from the trip one to say I was personally
harassed by Doobie cuz I'm black. For real. For real.
>> $5 from Will from Texas says, "What Destiny is leaving
out is that this is Destiny's underage victim. Both in that he
supported doxing her and that he tried to traffic her. Thank
you for the $5 traffic. I don't know that part. >> Uh they
that well that's really so I don't agree with this, right? Because
my understanding is he didn't know that she was underage at the
time. Um but what they're referring to is them like him making
plans or referring to plans for them to like meet up IRL when
they were like or whatever. >> But again at the time so
far as I'm aware he didn't know the story was under >> so
I don't think that's true. >> $10 from Odasher says Wick
where's the video of Destiny showing where Lauren de Laguna works?
So we we litigated that already. Um we're not going to go back.
$20 from Grassroots Hedgeimon to say Destiny in 2016 would be
Destiny in 2025's ideal cellmate.
$2 from the trip one to say to the 666 people in chat. I should
ask. Come on. Hold on. Give me a second. $5 from Will from Texas.
Um Wick, can you ask Destiny on my
police report against Solo, >> even if he isn't going with
a lawsuit?
>> Uh I will ask him next time I see him if you remind
me. Okay.
$20 from Grassroots Hedgemont. Destiny is a child enthusiast,
sociopath, and that's the only thing me and Dubbie agree on.
Merry Christmas. Well, thank you for your $20.
$5 from Nunion Star. Merry Christmas, Wick, Destiny, and the
ever generous hedgeimon. Merry Christmas to you. Grassroots Hedgeimon
for 20 between Dubbie and Destiny. No matter who wins, I win.
Okay, thank you for the $20.
$2 from Rristwit says, "Have you ever had on your computer?"
Easy end.
Uh $20 from Alexander Ren at Wick. Can you get Dubbie to explain
what the process would be to turn it over and preserve records
a records court in this case? Go ahead. >> I'm assuming
you would speak to your lawyer. They would uh organize with the
police to meet up and have you turn over any copies of that.
Um with the understanding that you didn't know that it was out
at the time and hopefully file a police report, let the police
know where you got it so they can track down the person who's
uh like uh producing and selling.
I think that's what a reasonable person would do. I don't know
why Destiny didn't do that and to my knowledge hasn't done that.
>> Okay.
Uh 20 Canadian dollars from Warpio to say so that whole spur
out about the Wally Max stuff was just doobie artistically reading
the worst possible intent into his words and crying and filibustering
whenever he's asked to consider a possible alternative explanation.
Thank you. >> I I think any reasonable person hearing the
possible alternatives would >> I'm still I'm still typing
so sorry >> Stupid cope. Uh, I think I think this idea
that you, you know, saying yes is more beneficial than saying
no, uh, is just stupid. And I think everybody knows this. I think
if you're trying to agree with that, I think you need to go >> $20
from grass. Tried them on. Destiny and Doobie can both suckart
a diesel engine in 20° weather. And I mean that with extreme
prejudice. What? Come on. Be nice to my guests. $5 from Arrow42.
Doobie, check your DMs. Don't let win.
Okay. Uh, $5 from morally neutral. Having it does not mean he
has it on his computer. It means he hasn't destroyed it and has
taken steps to preserve it in accordance with the law. Thank
you for >> Yeah, that's cope. >> $5 from Grassroot
Hedgemont. If I had a dollar for every child has that loves him,
I would be losing money like I invested in Enron. Damn, Grassroots
Hedgeimon. That's uh that's pretty brutal. Two pounds from Arabian
Stacey. I stand by every slur I call destiny vermin.
Okay. $5 from Nick Castanza. Is Dubie capable of admitting to
being >> Oh, yeah. I think so. >> Okay. $20 from
>> Oh, I did do this. I said I I don't necessarily think
the emails were harassment. Um given that he didn't lie. I think
there's basically a debate there to be had on like the harassment
portion I think is basically you have to argue it's like totally
wrong, totally not his place to inform her parents about the
trafficking. And I do agree with that, but I think everyone agrees
it was trafficking and then like,
oh man, it's rough, right? Yeah. >> Grassroot. When did
Wicked Supreme >> 17, right? >> So during that the
town hall Yeah. So I was very scared about being a 17-year-old
earlier, I think. So during the town hall, when I asked you when
I asked you if you'd spoken about that 17-year-old about anything
prior to >> and you think this prior to them turning 18,
you said yes. Right. No, I didn't
pressing duty for something else you >> No, I didn't. I
said no. I said, here's the thing. I said specifically this,
and if you can see the thing, when that person was >> Oh.
Oh, you didn't do that. Oh, I mean, I guess that's pretty bad.
I think it's less bad. >> 17. Uh, they wanted to ask me
questions about their given that they're gay. They wanted to
navigate. Not even I refuse to even answer those questions. >> I'm
not saying you're sex with him. Oh, you see you refused to answer.
I I don't think you said that during the >> Okay. I mean,
the the thing shows in there I refused to answer any questions.
And here was the thing that's honest about it, Dubie. And I can
give you evidence to back this up. When that person was 18, about
18 and 4 months in December, the person just started throwing
themselves at me. Now, Dubie, I'm going to tell you something.
You know, there's a word to describe me and it's not groomer.
You know what it is? >> What is it? >> It's called
lecher. I'm a leerous man. Now, I can give you like when ocean
flies basically
at me because I said I'd two 21 year olds even given my age.
I went out to the bar and club and I did hook up with two 21
year olds. >> Yeah, I'm not opposed to that. >> Okay.
So, you would agree that groomers wrong? You would say Niklot's
a lecher. He's not a groomer. >> No, I do think you're
a groomer. >> How am I a groomer? What? When? Who did I
groom?
>> I think you're misrepresenting what you said about the
17-year-old. >> Oh, the thing I just said about the parents,
uh, Saba just basically put that off. >> Oh, no, no, but
I I'm just telling you I didn't I didn't have those conversations.
I don't I understand you're saying this now, but I don't think
it's >> Okay. I'm just telling you I'm telling you to be
>> So, hold on. Wait. Let me ask you. Let me I want to
see how honest you are right now. Okay. So, when I ask you about
uh the
actually I'm just going to go through the list. So, I also said
that you tried to help some Muslim guys in some server justify
child marriage. Is that true? >> Uh I did that in the sense
I believe you should be able to argue any position. I do not
agree with that, but I've argued for genocide before. I argued
for other I believe it's the job to play devil's advocate for
everything. >> And you also and you also said that uh you
also argued for the age of consent to be lowered, right?
>> no. What I said specifically, >> but we we got
a I got a recording town >> Didn't I didn't I say that?
Okay. So, here's my position when it comes to that. If you want
to know my honest position, it's a form of political realism.
In my state, the age of consent is 16. You understand that, right?
>> Okay. So my theory is this and I want people to know
and we could have actually a philosophical discussion given my
political theory. I'm a political realist in the tradition of
hobbs and schmidt. Would you like me to explain that? >> It's
relevant. Okay. So I believe that the original state is a war
of all against all. People have friends and enemies. So my theory
is when we go about doing moral shaming we exacerbate conflicts.
Our natural emnity heightens. The best way to handle this, I
believe, if you want to tell someone in my state that they that
they shouldn't have relations with a 16-year-old is go through
legislative means and enact that in law. I think when you start
to go from a moral uh let's say pundit to do that, you exacerbate
conflict and claim. >> Okay. Just just for my edification,
um so you you uh mentioned I think it was Schmidt. Um I think
he's the friend enemy distinction guy. Are you a believer in
the friend enemy distinction? the fine wine for my friends, shotguns
for my enemies. >> I Yes, I believe doobie is an enemy
of mine and if there was no laws, I would probably kill him.
>> That's reasonable. >> I'm I'm telling you that.
So, I believe laws exist. So, that natural state of dies down.
>> If if there were no laws, would you a
>> No. I find that gross.
>> Because I just I look at pictures and I think someone
that young uh I don't have attraction. I'm a natural. Do you
often look at pictures of 13-year-olds?
>> Okay. So, I would be a normal male teophile. A normal
male teophile means that you find women in their early 20s most
attractive. Uh, it starts at about 16, but it increases and it
peaks in its early 20s. That would basically be it.
>> Yeah. But you did say that you find it like a it's like
an ego boost when like a 15-year-old >> No, no, not 15-year-old.
That was 17-year-old. And I can bring someone in here. No, I
didn't say 50. Do no said 15 and I said that was a lie. What
happened? I can >> hold on. I asked you specifically. >> No,
I didn't say No, I did not say that. That's a lie. >> You
started going on about how you have like an ego or whatever.
>> No, no, no. What I said is this. No, I didn't say 50.
Now you're lying. What I said is Okay. You want to know the context
for that? What happened was this >> I know the context,
but you said it. >> Okay, here it is. But I'm telling you
what, what it is now. What happened was specifically this. There
was an Eric server when I was on cam. I found out that there
was someone who was 15 that did find me attractive in the text
and we can bring Chandler in here who could uh verify that that
one. I said, "Oh, I got to stay away from that. I got to go away
from that." >> You said it was like an ego boost, >> No,
not for the 15. For the 17-year-old, I actually found the 15
kind of creepy. >> 17-year-old was the ego boost. The
>> Okay. Okay. So, that's number one. And number two, there
was no uh grooming because here's the thing about it. Can't you
tell? Wouldn't I be a poor groomer? I'm crude. The only way that
I've gotten away with this in my life is my looks. I don't feel
the need to groom. It would just be pathetic for me. >> Gotten
away with Wait, >> the only reason >> you shouldn't
say gotten away with this when we're talking about like you >> No,
not you. Okay. What I mean by gotten the only reason that I would
be even able to hook up and score with those two 21 year olds
is because the way that I look. Here it is. Given the way that
>> I was concerned about the 21 year olds, we're talking
about the 17-year-old that you were speaking about like sex.
No, I didn't speak with any >> and the the 15-year-old
that that you said you were like >> No, I didn't. No, that
that's okay. Here it is. And I'm going to tell you that. So,
number one, the 15-year-old kind of creeped me out. I'm just
telling you that right now. It was the 17-year-old girl that
I got flattered. I'm just telling you that. Second, the other
per the one that you're talking about, there was no grooming
cuz I refused to talk or have any conversations. And here's the
weird thing. There was never I didn't even know that there was
any feeling that he had anonymous until like when he was 18.
>> Pastor Ad got a big tip from Congress that Wick is registering
this live stream with their massive library is going to sue you
>> months and started throwing. >> He could do that.
He could do that totally stealing his cont.
>> Okay, I'm done arguing in Discord. I'm done arguing
in Discord. We should actually cover some of the content from
today. Me. Okay, I'm done arguing. Wick should keep rolling the
content though. How does Wick go? I'm tired after like 4 hours
and he's got like 700 viewers.
How does he not just churn through people and keep making money?
What is he doing? Are you not even listening? No, I'm just arguing
in Discord. I'm literally I'm literally just arguing in Discord.
I said I was arguing in Discord. That's what I'm doing. That's
my bad. Okay, I'm done. I'm done. I'm done. I'm entertaining
you guys. One sec. One more second. Okay. I'm All right. I'm
done. That was the last one. All right. All right. We're good
to go. I'm going back to my Discord. I'm I'm just chilling my
Discord. I'll ask Dooby if he wants to hop on and chat about
this a little bit. And then what else do we have going on here
today? Are you working with Dan? No. Although Dan Dan did send
me a really funny message that I can't that I can't share with
you guys. Okay,
surely. Can I I'm going to ask. Hold on. I'll ask him if I could
share it. It is really funny and it is
obviously indicative of the double standard.
I love Dan. You shouldn't love Dan. Dan's got a lot of problems.
Okay. But realistically, he's probably a less bad person than
Destiny by like a lot. Okay, I can't. God damn it. Oh, whatever.
Whatever. Whatever. Okay. What was I even going to do today?
Okay.
What was I even going to do today? Okay. All right. Uh, I have
other content. We're going to go through all the fallout that
led to this today. Okay. Go through all the fallout that led
to this [__] And
let me just find it and then we'll start it. And then I need
to use the bathroom, get another drink of water, and then we
will continue. Oh, wait. We're going to go to the beginning of
this. Was Doobie arguing with other people at the beginning.
It's wall to-wall wick content stealing today. Let's do it. Let's
do it. We're going to watch this doobie thing. I forgot it was
going to be the doobie thing. God damn. Slap drama a little bit.
Quick question about denims. Is it common for her community to
act on her behalf? And has CPS ever been called before in this
space? Because it never crossed my mind that was a possibility
till it actually happens. That community seemed like a bunch
of do nothings. Well, no, no, no. Bad empanadas community isn't
a bunch of do nothings. They do call in like actual harassment
to people in a lot of cases, right? It was random topics and
boring as Oh, okay. Well, I could go do other stuff as well.
There's other there's other stuff. We can cover some of the stuff
from this morning. The esports Batman thing, the spider thing.
We can go cover that stuff and then we can cover what else did
I have here? Oh, Pisco did a whole statement on it. I could cover
the drama from the Pisco Discord. I assume most people are caught
up, but in case you aren't caught up and you're wondering how
all these conversations started today,
you yourselves, Cam, is that the video you sent me? Because we
might check out that when we go to the Candace stuff later as
well. Okay, but I might as well form drama for a little bit.
I'll see if people want to come on and talk. We'll see what's
up. Yeah. So, I think the issue is uh Clad Thumper that I do
believe Denim's community is like a do nothing community. I don't
believe they really harass people, but Ban Panata's community,
there's crossover there with communities that do actually go
out of their way to sort of harass people, right? And the whole
point of this conversation is just because Denims agrees on like
Ethan kind of sucks, does that mean she's responsible for all
the other?
I don't think so. You should watch the call before Destiny came
in though. Oh, is there a call before Destiny came in? That's
good. That's Destiny in. And then this is somebody. Hold on.
Is there someone else? If there isn't, no, it's just this guy.
Okay, we're being told Oh, hold on. There's a loss and Harrison
call. Oh, well, we do want to watch the loss and Harrison call
>> cuz I was just this guy for being a total cultist in
Wix Discord. So, I will cover the loss and call. All right, I
will cover the lost and call. Yeah. Um, with with the Riyle thing
and the cyclone thing, I don't know how close. So, what I understand
is Riyle posted like some online username for him. I don't know
how many steps that is removed from finding his real identity.
It might be really close and therefore that was really bad. In
any case, I believe Ry was banned
and
I'm trying to think of what happened after that, but it was like
he was drunk and he apologized to the guy. Like I I understand
that doesn't undo everything, but it's not like he went, "Oh,
I have total malice right now. This guy from a sober state of
mind. I'm going to do something crazy." You know what I mean?
So, I haven't actually looked into it completely. Maybe that
guy needs to go. I made a bet my best judgment call at that point
in time and I was like, "Okay, you could ban him, but like I'll
probably unban him eventually." that guy accept Riyle's apology?
I don't even remember to be honest with you. But really, if he
did accept the apology, it probably doesn't mean much because
then he might think Riyle was going to dox him. So like, would
it be an apology accept under duress? Hard to say, right? Who
is that guy? He's a former mod in my
You Well, I think it was like I think Riyle was like, "Oh, I'm
going to go crawl this guy's Twitter and like find posts about
like things." I dude I think he was just going to try to find
embarrassing information on the guy which um yeah is bad if you
go try to find like that and you're publishing that leads to
their identity it's obviously really bad. I didn't go into it
fully. I don't remember how close it was. I don't remember from
what I understood it was the threat that people were most upset
about like I'm going to find stuff to to mock you and like destroy
you in this public space.
I think people were mostly mad about the threat when Riyle did
get banned
was my like recognition. Ri no Riyle I don't believe Riyle did
actually dock somebody. I think his like steps removed. But again,
I don't I don't recall. We could go look into it. I could go
find my DMs from the whole Paragon thing. Or not DMs, but the
mod chat. How long ago was this? Months ago.
It would have been while me and Destiny were still friends, I
think. >> Yeah, nice person. >> Okay, I'll hit play
here. I'm going grab some water. Give me two seconds.
What's up, fellas? >> Oh, this I'm joking. >> I know,
right? All right. I'm not here to give what you want. I'm here
to represent DG and not uh not just defend our pope.
So, I I agree with you about the cartel and I understand why
legality doesn't play a big factor in this. Like, I have the
same position. If we could uh smash the cartel,
um I'm all for it. I just don't trust this administration to
do that. So, I get you there. >> Yeah. Um, secondly, do
you support peace goes like uh like what he does the political
stuff he he does like covering Trump cases and all that stuff?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think it's interesting.
>> So, if that's why I want $3
I feel like people fail to get nuance. A community can be imperfect
or too mean or edgy, but that's not the same as being guilty
of real threatening. >> Okay, I'm back now.
Yes, that is true. donator. I didn't see who donated that, but
that is true. Donator. Okay, that Yeah, that can happen.
Oh, I think Duby might hop on in a second as well. Let me just
let him know that he can hop on.
So, that can happen. And that is the whole point, right? It's
that like nobody in my community is saying we have to like go
and dox these people and we have like a mission against them,
right? Like obviously that's not the case. Um,
I don't believe anybody, like I don't believe that I've seen,
sorry, I know I've not seen a single piece of evidence that somebody
in my community has doxed or harassed someone around these people.
Unless you consider harassment like reviewing their content and
then like laughing at them for being stupid. If that's harassment,
then I am guilty of harassment, right? Um, you got to give dub
for harping on Lauren getting doxed. I mean, I can say that's
not the best line to go down, but unfortunately for everyone,
right?
Unfortunately for basically everybody.
Um, there's a way to make that argument. I think you do it entirely
around the Riyle stuff and not the Laurens stuff. I don't think
the Riyle stuff's lost media. I think I think people I feel like
I've seen that
but I can't remember it specifically.
Um, and as far as like Riyle, I don't think Riyle docks somebody.
I don't I don't think so.
I think it was like the threat that people were upset about.
So, um and by the way, banned for that threat made very clear
to him that that threat is not okay. It's not cool, right? Um
well, I don't know if they have the clips of the rile stuff.
Sya,
>> Hello. How's it going, Dubie? What's up? >> Uh
not much. What can I do for you?
>> Oh, nothing. I just was going to see >> I have
something I have something funny. So, I don't know if you guys
follow the nightcloud stuff at all. So, I said in that like little
section that I remembered listening to something where he was
talking about lowering the age consent. I'm going to post it
in your uh I'll post in your general chat. Okay? Like he's it's
very explicit. So, like for anybody that was questioning whether
or not I was like unfair to the guy or something, like it's very
straightforward. He's talking about these kids coming on to them
and if they come on to them, then they obviously have autonomy.
It's like super straightforward. So, just a flag.
wait. What is this? >> It's a ne guy that came on at the
end. It's It's really fun if you want to listen to it because
he was swearing that he didn't say thing that he says in the
video. >> Someone posted this in the jet chat and said,
"Guys, Expedia is harassing me."
>> Oh god. Uh, the cold emails. I think it's a little more
nuanced than that in terms of like denouncing what Cyber was
doing or saying it was bad. I can say it was bad. I just don't
think I feel like I don't know. Intent plays into it quite a
bit, right? like what was your what could be reasonably like
determined to be your intent? I think things that help Cybo a
lot is that he made a NickM complaint Nick National Center for
Children like child protection or whatever. He made a complaint
that didn't even reference Destiny that was just about the trafficking
before any of this stuff became public, right? It's like there
there are a lot of things there where people are like, "Oh, it's
just strictly that he hates Destiny. That's why he did this."
And it's like, okay, like I think the concern there for me would
be if he hates Destiny, was he lying to Rose to try to get her
to go and
and like join the lawsuit? I don't think so. I don't think there's
any
Right. So anyway, um let me find what you were talking about
in gen chat. This is the video. >> Hold on. This is the
guy that was yelling at Doobie. Were you like pedo? Was he basically
accusing you of him? >> He's accusing me of lying about
him. uh saying that he wants to lower the age consent or whatever
the but if you just listen to this like it's very
>> Okay, this is the guy who's going crazy on Dubbie at
the end of that call there. We're about to watch you talk to
Lawson right now.
>> I don't know how this would have gone. It's kind of
cringe that he just leans into being like um a cultist now. I
I
>> Yeah, messaged him in the gen chat was like, "Hey, you're
a cultist." And he's like, "Yeah, I am."
Okay. Well, Jesus. >> Yeah, it sucks. >> It is what
it is.
>> Yeah. Okay.
All right. Where are we?
>> What's happening? This is the video of the guy. >> One
minute. What about the age of >> Whoops. Whoops. Whoops.
This is the guy who's going super hard on Doobie about essentially
kind of >> pentjack.
Pause. One minute. What about the age of consent?
>> Okay. So, I basically said the reason I think or am
open to a different age of consent because I'm consistently or
especially in here and even in the real world where the 16-year-old,
no one does it to the degree here, but I had uh Baby Blue making
comments to me basically.
>> Um, she's a 17-year-old girl >> and they're they're
throwing, you know, people heard it in chat. The problem is they're
coming on to me. I'm not coming on to them. So you're saying
young people constantly throw themselves on you and that's why
you want to rethink the age of consent from 18 to lower
>> because if they do this obviously they have autonomy.
I'm saying most men are not in this
>> that is um sincerely like disturbing motivated reasoning
right there >> position whereas I am >> guys when
your dog humps your leg this is bordering on some YMS stuff.
Your dog humps your leg that shows autonomy. Okay, that's that
your dog is coming on to you. That that dog has autonomy, >> I'm
in a position where they're the ones actively commenting to me.
It's not the other way around. You understand my point? And if
that's the case, how can they not have autonomy when I consistently
have this experience,
>> right? So, so I want to so I want to understand. Okay.
So, your line of reasoning is that oh, most of them are young
and they throw themselves on you and that that and that's like
indicative of what? that it should be lowered
>> that they have autonomy that they clearly have autonomy
if they're because it's not a Harvey Weinstein where I'm some
old guy with a position of power manipulating them. They're throwing
themselves at me. >> Do you think do you think if it was
lowered you would have given the same attention back >> if
it was like for example if the person was 17 or 16?
>> Uh if it was pro I guess my way that I look at it like
this if it was legal. Yes. Because they're the one initiating
it. I'm not I'm never the one initiating this. I'm never the
one I mean I would especially with young people. I would make
sure that the person has autonomy. That's really it. Yeah. >> Okay.
I see what you mean. Never mind. >> Yeah. Honest about
that seems very straightforward, right? So like
>> I mean it seems like motivated reasoning. Yeah, for
sure. I
I I would wonder how dumb this guy is. Like if this guy's like
significantly impaired and you're
he might not really know what he's saying. >> He's a pretty
smart. I think he's a pretty intelligent guy. He's just uh >> if
he's okay, if he's able to like ponder conditional hypotheticals,
then yeah, that seems like motivated reasoning, and I'd be concerned.
>> Okay. Um, how do you think I did, Mr.
>> Uh, I have I have notes, but one second.
>> Go for it. So, I don't have long I have uh very limited
time, but I will stick around for like maybe two, three minutes,
five minutes. >> One second. I I literally forgot I was
streaming at some point. I think I argued on Discord in Wix Discord
for like five full minutes without realizing I was live. Without
like thinking about being live is crazy. So I just had to point
out one more thing in there and now I'm done. Definitely done.
Definitely totally done. Okay. All right. Um
so I think >> really quickly so I think if I had criticism
myself um it would be to not get hung up on the Lauren de Laguna
thing and focus on the Willie Mack DMs. I think that's the only
criticism I'd have myself. But other than that, I think that
when we went and went to the Willy Mac thing, I think it was
pretty straight obvious. He's >> well through that entire
>> unfortunately like he just has to lie completely there,
right? Cuz like really the question is when you pull up these
DMs and I'll pull them up on screen right now. Um when you pull
up these DMs, the question is bro, you just let you let me know
you still have CP videos saved on your computer. You knew it
was alleged that she was underage. You still have them. Do we
see how this is? So Destiny's opinion is simultaneously that
he is protecting himself for his court cases but also speaking
so colloquially because he believes these will remain private.
Both of those those are in congruent right he can't do both of
those things at the same time so he has to pick a lane on that
and then based on that he is by these messages right like either
he is hiding things for his court case in which case why are
you why not just say no I
if you're hiding things for your court case and you are what
is it you you're like being sorry not hiding if you're trying
to be transparent because if this could all be subpoenaed for
your court case you're not trying to give them any reason you
did exploation then just say I've never had child or something
right I actually that's just the answer in all of these cases.
Sorry. It isn't literally it's just the answer is I don't I've
never had child on my computer. I've I've never retained child.
I don't retain child.
Rose didn't send me child. Any of those options are fine. But
instead of saying instead of responding to Willy's question about
why he's retaining,
Destiny gives a I don't even know 100% of her age is legitimately
less than 18 when these were taken. When what were taken? Wait,
when what were taken? Destiny,
not the videos.
What do you What do you even mean? Like, it's it's clear what
the object is the entire time he speaks.
And I do think it looks good when you focus on these, right?
Like you you're focusing on these and I think it's almost impossible
to [__] them up. Like Destiny,
there's no other way to come away. There's no possible way you
could come away from this unless you were a total cultist and
say, "No, this guy definitely wasn't admitting to anything here."
>> Yeah, I agree.
>> And then the Lauren de Laguna stuff, sticking on that.
It's not even that like it's entirely possible that he did intentionally
go there and intentionally like walk down there just to with
her, but it's like the dog whistling thing, right? If you think
somebody's dog whistling with like an okay sign, >> you
it unfortunately when they say no, you kind of just have to let
it go and move on. >> Yeah. No, I think that's fair.
>> Yeah. What else was there? There was this stuff focusing
on the fact that he docks Rose. Now, he has like some argument
there for why he docks Rose. I do think the Facebook messages
is pretty funny, right? Do we lost on Cyber too? Fair. Um, well,
it's hard not to lose on Caiba because Saiba's like
I think Caiba's stuff is like weird on an automatic level. I
do not think it rises to harassment because I do believe that
like he didn't send multiple messages like after the point he
wasn't getting contact. I think he sent some cold messages to
try to say, "Hey, I think you guys should reach out on this case."
>> That's what he did. Right. Like otherwise, it was a
back and forth between him and Rose.
>> Yeah. So, I I
agree that it's weird, a little bit weird, inappropriate. Um
I think he initially he said it was like there's like an implicit
threat and I I don't know where the [__] that's coming
>> Um I'm [clears throat] not as familiar with this type
of stuff. >> No, there's no implicit threat. Destiny basically
says when I think there's some line in a in an email that says
I'm disappointed you haven't reached out to her to like um Joan
Peters or something. But I I just don't see how you could possibly
interpret that as a threat. I will say that I have to have a
zero tolerance about this going forward that like you if there's
ever evidence of something like this like it's an automated ban.
It's an automatic ban going forward. If you're reaching out to
people um and possibly like thinking you're going through a block
or possibly like reaching out to people adjacent to them to communicate
with them. That has to be an automatic ban going forward because
I can't I can say in this one case I'm going to read intention
in here and be okay with it and not perma banan this guy. But
going forward I do have to let it go that sorry I do have to
autoban for it cuz I don't want to ever be accused of enabling
or encouraging people doing this. Like that's what my concern
would be would be one preventing somebody from reaching out to
people who aren't as good intentioned or aren't you
I don't know how to explain it. I just I don't want that at all.
That's a threat but not saying he wants to kill Jaw and Queen.
Yeah. I just don't Unfortunately for Destiny all of the twoear
sub by the way. Wait, you understand I make thousands of dollars
a month right? You understand I wouldn't risk my reputation for
somebody giving me $5 a month for two years. I make more on one
stream than Cyba's entire two-year subscription. That wouldn't
make any sense. That's like a totally That's a totally broken
incentive. Sorry, I'm responding to a chatter.
>> So, I I do have to go, but um >> Yeah, it's fun.
It's a good time. >> Yeah, I thought it was cool. Um I
wish I would have mentioned just one more time that with the
Wicked Supreme stuff that everybody from PV had to come out and
disavow Destiny, lying about him and say that none of this is
true. He's just totally made this up about about Destiny. And
I don't believe Wicked Supreme has ever lied about Destiny in
any way that is remotely close to that. So I would wonder why
Destiny thinks he's justified in doxing him now. >> Yeah,
I think I think with those portions and the World portion and
the even the esports portion, right? I think and Pisco especially,
I think all these port like it's pretty obvious he's just being
a piece of [__] I don't think you can listen to his
justification there and think anything other than that unless
you're like a loss and you know. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Unfortunately, um
the real bottom of the pit in terms of like Blackpill is realizing
that 80% of the Twitch pole adjacent community is a
>> Yeah, that's true. Okay, I got to go. Have a good day.
>> All right. Yeah, thanks for coming on. See you later,
Duby. Bye. Oh, um Oh, man. I could have shown him. This is what
I would have gone to. Okay, Duby. Duby, are you listening? Oh,
okay. Hold on. Wait. Maybe maybe I'll wait. Um, yeah. Oh, is
that the private group chat that somebody was saying there was
a private group chat where you guys harassed people?
I see. I I'd heard about this and then I didn't get a chance
to ask anyone. Somebody told me about this yesterday. Wasn't
there a private group chat that was conspiring on harassing her?
It's like, no, I don't think so. I'm pretty sure Cy only told
people about this like way after the fact. Um,
but that's that makes more sense. Okay, I got it. Um,
I was just going to say on the Lauren de Laguna front, you can't
do as much, but there is the video of Darius trying to go to
the address that was doxed by Destiny for Riyle,
right? And then trying to ask for him, going to like their door
and asking for him live on his stream. Again, not anything close
to what So, so like in terms of like I think obviously if you
believe that if you believe that what Cyber did is evil, I do
believe that Darius because Destiny had doxed this guy and said
he was bad. Darius going to that guy's house and trying to get
into a confrontation with him. That's orders of magnitude worse
again, right? Oh, he said he was going to fight/ assault him
as well. It was a direct threat. Okay. Yeah.
So, so like again
I think probably Darius would have to be permabanned for anybody
in in DGG to seriously consider this double standard or sorry
to seriously consider enforcing the standard on me.
And again, Darius went here entirely just here's the video. I
don't think I'm going to play it right now. I'll probably wait
until it's uh like good to play it. But Darius went entirely
to try to start a fight to try to get in a confrontation to harass
the person explicitly.
Cyber is objectively
right objectively. Oh, also imagine using Cyber standards for
the Anna stuff. Yeah. It's just like it's totally disingenuous
when the standards get applied. And that's like what DGG is known
for now. They just they try to apply standards to other people
that they totally fail to uphold that Destiny himself totally
fails to uphold at all points in time, right? Like this is obviously
significantly worse than the Cyber stuff. So if Destiny banned
Darius, you'd ban Cyba. No, I'm telling you this is significantly
worse. This is stated malice. This is stated I'm going to harass
this guy. I'm going to try to fight this guy.
Caiba was trying to help. God bless him. Okay. Caiba is like
our Lenny. Okay. And up until this point, he hasn't killed a
woman yet. He's only killed some rabbits. And we're trying to
make sure that he never killed a woman. Okay. So, realistically,
letting him go to another community is probably dangerous because
we're preventing a woman from getting strangled. Okay. Cyber
understands you cannot do this.
Sybo is doing quid proquo harassment.
Okay, Jastaster Tai, you understand? Hop in the Discord. I'll
unban you if you're banned. Hop in the Discord and we'll just
talk through it. We'll just talk through it, man. Hop in the
code.
Hold on. Is this Jastaster Tai guy here? Jaster. Yeah, you're
here. Hop in the Discord, bro. Who the [__] is Lenny
of Mice and Men? I also feel bad cuz I'm like on Saiba. I legitimately
think Caiba was like trying to help Pixie in a way he didn't
like tell me about it. I do not believe he was like lying about
Destiny. I don't think there was anything like that, right? I
just I believe that Cyber had good intentions the entire time
and was balancing concerns and was not acting in a way that was
overtly malicious towards anybody.
Now, being empathetic to Pixie's concerns does result in bad
things for Destiny, but it's not like he is, you know, telling
Pixie she needs to pay attention to Rose and that it's really
bad, right? It's you see the email from Joan saying, "Hey, we
would like to reach out to this person. could you provide their
contact info?
Right? Like it's not close. Don't ban desenters. I didn't ban
desenters.
And it's like I understand that I'm basically saying that like
I trust this person to not do this again. Now
you guys think Destiny's going to do that to say like well if
Darius if Darius does
I'll
anything you think he's ever going to put his reputation on the
line for Darius? I mean he kind of is but but he Destiny knew
about this by the way. And then he still when Darius came in
and joked about going to with Lauren de Laguna, Destiny still
let that happen. When Darius had gone and to people who Destiny
had doxed placed, you can be really into this. I talk to you
about it if you want. By the way, also I'm letting people come
on and argue this position. And I've never banned somebody in
the community who's like, "Oh, you should ban Cybo." I didn't
ban anybody who said it in the Discord. I didn't remove any messages.
I just was like, "Yeah, I think that's I think it's like reasonable
to think that it's it's like bad enough to ban somebody."
Again, I think the mitigating circumstances there are that Caab
tried to intervene in ways that involved authorities that didn't
involve Destiny. So, shows that it's not just purely mal maliciously
motivated from him.
And there's the mitigating circumstance, the fact that he was
doxed himself. And I'm like, okay, that's like probably a more
severe punishment than just being banned from this community.
And again, if Destiny had any proof that Cybo was like lying
to somebody, was trying to get them in under false pretenses,
was doing anything of the sort, then this would flip again, right?
If Cybo was lying to go after Destiny, I would ban him
Like, that's just on the record. I don't I don't want The whole
point the whole purpose of being like in opposition to Destiny
on a fundamental basis is that he is a lying disingenuous piece
of [__] and he ruins political discourse just by
involving himself, right? He is like a horrible person who can't
be trusted to make moral like claims, moral arguments about anything.
It's fortunate that what Destiny does doesn't require lying about.
Yeah, that's true. Oh boy. Also, just like a fun little thing.
This is kind of interesting. Hey, look, it's Oshara again. Do
Do we call CPS?
Oh,
apparently some DJers were thinking you might want to call CPS
on Ethan Klein. Uh, is Odashara going to be banned from all of
your communities or was Mau's kick? I have no idea. Um, sorry
if this is off topic, but what is the current take Pisco has
on Destiny doxing esports Batman? I don't know actually. Evil
Johnny Bravo, I would love to talk to Pisco about it. I just
don't think I I offered to in private have this discussion with
Pisco. Okay. I offered to have this discussion in private with
Pisco.
I have not gotten a message back. I don't know if that's because
he doesn't check his messages. In fact, I'll I'll try to reach
out through a proxy or something, somebody who I knew I know
does DM him, but like I'm like I just want to discuss my side
of it, right? Surely it' be this is bad, right, Pisco? So all
I want is to say to Pisco that in the future if you do ever decide
to talk about this or you are in scope for it, I'd like to give
my side of this so that when you say that there's like harassment
or threats or something or you say there's like yeah harassment
in general that you know like the other side of it that you understand
what's going on and that you don't make claims that you don't
want to litigate that are like indictments in my community.
That's all. So I don't I don't want him to come out and argue
my side of it. I don't expect him to go back and backtrack on
a position. just that if he were to argue it the next time, he
would know what my position is. So if he doesn't want to look
into it, right? So there'd be one of two possibilities. Either
he's looked into it himself and he wants to make his own claims
or the other possibility is that he hasn't looked into it himself.
He wants to maintain neutrality, but he does give people for
the sake of their argument because he doesn't want to look into
it. He says if that's true, but then he fails to clear that up
on stream that he says it as if it's a fact. And I would just
like him to in the future be cognizant of my disagreement so
that if he doesn't want to litigate it, he can say, "Well, you
know, allegedly this is what happened." Or if he does actually
go through and look through it himself and he decides, then I
could argue with him, right? Probably easy for him to understand
now that he's had Destiny spreading lies about him. Maybe. Yeah.
Look at friends.